Oh my god.
Are you an actual bad boy?
Are you...
Yeah?
What's the baddest thing you've done?
Yeah, name five.
Yeah?
Oh my god.
You're a goddamn criminal!
You're goddamn crazy!
That is hardcore, man.
Whoa!
that's
that's that's messed up man that's so messed up
like right off the bat
oh shit you guys don't hear it are these just too quiet
there's no way you guys don't hear this okay I'm turning it
up yeah wait they said it in general you guys don't hear it
okay give me a sec let me fix this
oh there you go no no no it's up to you you can continue
streaming something else no you have to end right away yeah
yeah you just end it well you can't even spectate people
that's messed up is that why they give us their are this
that why they they made a skip of our stream key to them so
they could send our tree well you gave your stream key did
you also give their credit card card number two so they can
charge.
Oh, I think I didn't do that.
Wait, you guys didn't give them your credit card number two
in the last three digits on the back?
I have to go do something really quick.
I'm sure that'll be all right.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's probably sure.
What are you going to do?
We're streamers.
We're a broker already.
Yeah.
yeah we're not even gonna get money we get eliminated in the
first four days yeah yeah so what is the first event we're
doing this for exposure yeah yeah yeah that's how they're
paying us yeah yeah yeah do you guys know uh the first event
like what the details are why don't we just a red light
green light is it red light green light didn't really
understand They're like there's boxes that you can hit to
get like benefits and stuff And I was like Mario Kart.
Yeah, it's like Mario Kart red light green light Like do you
die if you move when the lights off because I didn't say
that Oh my god, what if it's like crab game?
I'm pretty sure this is basically like crab game but spooky
Because did you see in the rules?
They were like you gotta be immersed in as if you're
actually in a haunted house And you got role play and stuff.
It's like GTRP But in Minecraft.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I think it's like craft game as where you can probably just
punch someone to make them move.
And then.
Oh, that's true.
But we're allies, right guys?
Yeah, we're allies.
Guys, right?
We're not going to punch each other, right?
Yeah, no, we're all friends.
Yeah.
We're all good.
If you punch Gumi and I, you're punching babies.
Hello.
Because we just installed Minecraft today.
I wouldn't want to do that.
You're a baby puncher.
She's so new to Minecraft.
She barely plays Minecraft.
Yeah.
I don't even have my own skin.
I'm a bear.
That's when you know I'm a baby.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Friends?
Yeah.
Oh, can you guys hear me?
Everybody's voice is coming out.
Oh, no, we can hear you.
It's just the quality is very terrible because there's a lot
of people on the server.
Okay, thank God.
So the more people are eliminated, the better the bandwidth.
Hey, guys, how's the volume, by the way?
Oh, did you guys see the animatronics?
Oh, yeah, the FNAF at home.
That's so cool.
Yeah, guys, chat, look, look, chat.
One of them looked.
That one's gone.
There's FNAF at home.
Wish FNAF.
Huh?
What the heck is...
You're Mike?
Your voice chat is so messed up.
Oh my god, we can't hear anything.
It's like...
Oh,
yeah, look at this server, though, guys.
It's actually crazy.
Um, let's see.
I'm gonna make sure it's sound, guys, just double checking
stuff for me.
Oh my gosh, I love your...
I love your skin.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm a bear farmer.
Hello.
That's the cutest thing in the world.
I'm here to farm.
I love it.
I'm new to Minecraft.
This is my first day.
I just installed it today.
Yeah, she just installed it.
She doesn't even know how to crouch.
Yeah, I don't even have my own skin.
That's when you know you should not, you should, like, let
me get through the first round as, like, a make a wish.
Yeah.
This is my make-a-wish to get through the first round
It is me, Doc.
We need to win.
Yeah, you can just call me Doc.
That's my name.
All right, I'll call you Doc McSuffins.
That's wrong.
is insane what do you mean yeah yeah what's the copyright
free version for legal reasons what is the name of this of
these guys for legal reasons what are their names we should
name them right now this one it's a good name for this one
oh my god um Ralph.
Oh, heck yes.
Oh my god.
This is Ralph.
Five nights at Ralph?
Uh-oh.
Okay, I think now we're going through legal territory now.
Now we're going back to maybe getting a cease and desist
letter.
Okay, how about Steve?
Oh my god, my favorite game.
Five nights at Steve.
Oh, Minecraft is Steve copyrighted.
Come on, that's quite easy.
No, maybe like Bartholomew.
Cookie.
Yeah.
Now you're cooking, Hannah.
That's actually a good name.
Yeah, what is it?
What if?
Yeah.
What if there's hide and seek in the next few days?
I've been looking around for good hiding spots.
Oh, is there actually hide and seek?
Wait, you're friends with the admin.
Ask her.
Ask her what the game is.
You're literally friends with the creators, ask them what
the games are.
You're right.
Let me ask.
Just be like, hey, I'll never tell people what the games
are.
But like, yeah, you know I'm not going to make it to the
next rounds, but I'm just curious.
What are the next couple of games?
Oh, I like that.
I like that.
Yeah, dokey.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Send that DM right now.
Don't worry, I have your stream open so you can send it
whenever.
Because you...
Oh, look.
This is a pretty good hiding place.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's actually insane.
I don't even know how I can get up there.
You can't see me at all.
Yeah, I can only see your name.
Wait, no, I don't even... Wait, where are you?
Where did you go?
Wait.
Where did you...
Do you not see me?
No, I don't.
Your name tag disappeared.
Yeah, your name tag disappeared.
Also, are we supposed to, like, reconvene somewhere?
I mean, when did they start the first game without us?
I don't know.
That would be pretty embarrassing if we just got instantly
eliminated.
All right, let me, uh, I'm gonna double check the
announcement.
Oh, apparently not...
Let's see, not everybody's in the server yet.
Wait, what the heck?
They're late?
They're 12 minutes late.
Eliminate them.
How dare they?
Eliminate them!
Right now!
Wait, if we eliminate the 12 people, only 8 people have to
be eliminated on the next one.
Because they're late.
Oh my god.
That means we get to go through the first round for free.
I think so too.
Nope, I don't even know where you are.
Oh, wait, I see you!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
How did you do that?
Slash TP.
And then you gotta run around and jump on that bush.
What the fuck?
That's the one I'm standing on.
I can barely see.
Okay.
can't even see anything.
Oh, you got this.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm standing right where you need to jump.
Am I standing in the right area?
Wait, maybe I'm gonna up the brightness.
How do I up the brightness?
I'm just gonna try and up the brightness.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, I up the brightness.
I still can barely see, but that's okay.
Run forward jump.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
You're hitting this wall you have to make it pass the wall
and then turn in oh no and apparently there's a parkour
course later oh i made it oh almost you made it one under oh
wait are you above me oh yeah yeah look on that yeah yeah
okay oh why is this so dark oh no i give up i'll just die
underneath you so they'll know that you're so they're like
oh we got the person so they'll run away and then you'll be
safe oh my god and then i split the money with yeah yeah
yeah and then you split any thousand dollars like 60 40 60
40 i i helped you get to the end if it wasn't for me
Oh, are we going to go to Japan to get it and you promised
to pay for part of it?
Oh, you did it!
You did it!
I did it, but I jumped away!
Okay.
No!
You keep jumping past it.
But like, if we all...
But if we're both on the same hiding spot, wouldn't we both
die at the same time?
No, because look, it's like...
Okay, get up here.
Get up.
I'm here.
me okay they can't see you they can't see me my no i keep
fucking okay make the jump hold your crouch button okay oh
my god pro minecraft strap oh my god we did it jump up here
and then you stay in that corner i'll stay in the other
corner okay because i can't see you yeah yeah you don't know
where i am i can't see anything either girl you just walked
into me
But I can't see anything.
Oh, wait, that's so smart.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God, we're going to win this.
We're going to win that $70,000, $60,000.
All right, so guys, I need...
All right, guys.
So this is a custom Minecraft horror map.
They actually made an entire installation for this.
Like, there was a whole folder.
Like...
Okay, we're only waiting on one person who's on tech issues.
Oh my god, who is that?
Call him out right now.
Who is it?
Call him out, admins.
Yeah, call him out.
Call him out on stream.
So they actually made an entire, like, world pack, and you
just, like, download.
You just download the file, and then, like, wait, is that
Mickey Mouse?
Oh my god, Mickey's in the server.
Oh my god.
I can't believe they got Mickey.
yeah so like basically like we don't even we're not even
using the minecraft launcher we're using a custom launcher
for this so like all your like texture packs resource packs
don't even don't even like show up for this one so like when
you install it everything is already there oh you're gonna
make tacos okay i'll talk to my chat then What?
Can you talk to my tattoo?
Okay, I'll talk to your chat as well.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll entertain your chat as well.
Are you gone yet?
Okay.
Oh, are you still here?
Yeah, tell a story that I would tell you your chat.
Okay, okay.
Let me know when you're gone.
I'm gone.
Okay, are you still here?
Okay, alright.
So people in Gumi's chat, uh, come to my... I stream on
YouTube.
You're stopping I knew you didn't do shit.
I knew you didn't do shit.
I just knew it.
I didn't leave because I knew it.
Well, I knew you didn't leave, so I was testing you.
I was testing you.
The CMU is still here and I.
I knew you didn't leave.
I'm not even going to tell you when I leave.
Just keep talking.
Okay.
Anyway, anyway, guys.
Anyways, so I was talking to my chat about this map because
I don't know if Gumi introduced it, but basically this is a
Twitch Rivals Minecraft.
Oh, hi, it came from Gumi's chat.
Oh, hey!
Hey!
Anyway, so this is basically full.
Everything in here was like custom made just for this event.
So there's like 150 participants.
And it's basically like Squid Game, but what if it's spooky?
So it's like a haunted mansion.
It's so funny because in the rules, they were like, please
role play and immerse your viewers and immerse all the other
participants as if you're really trapped in the haunted
house.
And I was like reading that.
I was like, what the fuck?
So, but it's actually crazy though.
The amount of detail and the amount of like, the amount of
like effort they put into this entire world because
everything is custom here.
Like, you see the resource packs, the, like, the voice chat
and everything, and, like, almost everything in here was
just, like, squid game, but, like, what if it's a haunted
mansion type deal?
And apparently there's going to be two games.
It's going to last, like, uh, six days or something, but
each day people get eliminated.
And apparently the first game is some red light, green light
thing.
Um, I read the rules for the first two games, because every
day is, like, two games, and I got so confused.
because I didn't even realize it was supposed to be red
light green light I was like looking at it I'm like this is
red light green light but maybe I'm illiterate um anyway uh
so I think like the first game 20 people gets eliminated and
then I don't know what happens the second game because I'm
gonna see if I can survive the first game uh and yeah
they're like you can have allies and everything oh yeah
apparently the rules was like you should not be swearing but
like I guess like you could swear on your own stream but
like not like during voice chat i assume but like i'm
already talking in voice chat so like oh this is gonna be an
issue but you're like no profanity so like yeah i'm pretty
sure i broke the rules already when it comes to profanity
but there's like 150 people here um only top 20 wins money
uh but don't worry we're just doing this for exposure
because I know there's like lots of Minecraft players on
here because there's a Minecraft event so like yeah we're
not gonna be making it to top top 20 because Minecraft
players are at a whole nother level they've been doing like
these Minecraft like the and what was it called the the
Minecraft championship like MCC shit like that they've been
doing this on the daily so so uh if we make it past day one
that's a win on my book um anyway it's fun though i got me
lots of uh gloomy's friends and talking to a lot of people
uh but yeah minecraft players are a whole another level when
it comes to mini games so like it'd be nice to just you know
survive the first day all right i hope gloomy shout was
entertained got like exposition for this uh tournament um
but yeah anyway if i if i don't live past day one then it's
rest week for me yay i get to it's a win-win if i make it
past day one wow i beat some minecraft players on day one if
i don't make it past day
so so it's a win-win honestly um but yeah a lot of yeah i
mean they got 100 i mean i mean they got 150 streamers that
is an accomplishment on its own because they managed to get
150 streamers to coordinate their schedules for this one
event and that's like i it's it's very difficult to get like
30.
time coordinating the schedule for like 30 people so think
about 150 in one place
um yeah it's actually crazy though it's crazy uh it's
minecraft streams not like they have i'm stuck i mean
they'll be playing minecraft anyway but it's basically like
a merge of like different streamers from different
communities there's like Spanish streamers too uh because
there's the the server that the discord server was um has
like uh instructions in both Spanish and English because
like I know like Minecraft is really really popular for uh
for like uh Spanish speakers as well so yeah there's there
were a lot of like Spanish speaking Minecraft players uh
earlier when i logged in and everything um so yeah i i was
so surprised i didn't realize minecraft i guess like
quackity it would make sense because quackity is like one of
their biggest streamers on twitch um but yeah minecraft is
like incredibly popular um uh for spanish speaker uh viewers
are you back yet did you make your taco okay guys anyway on
gloomy's chat uh For those who don't know me, I'm Doki Bird.
You can find me on Twitch right now if you really wanted to
have some streamer interactions.
And...
I mean, she's not...
How is she gonna know?
I'm surprised we haven't started yet.
What are we still waiting on?
Like, what are...
what are we also have you guys heard about twitch prime
gloomy chat so twitch prime is basically uh you can
subscribe to your favorite twitch streamer for free for one
month um if you have twitch prime so click that button uh
okay before you click that button go to the search bar type
out dokey bird uh it's only exclusive to like dokey bird
channel too by the way uh because I have a special deal
right now.
Hey, hey, Gumi.
You're back.
And Gumi's channel, too.
You can also Twitch Prime.
Yeah, it's exclusive on Gumi's channel and my channel.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The Twitch Prime stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
You came at just the right time.
I was talking about our Twitch Prime sponsor.
You have to remember, I have wireless headphones.
I was listening the entire time.
Yeah, yeah.
So you heard me, like...
Show us, right?
Like, both of us.
Yeah, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was talking.
I was hyping you up, Gumi.
Yeah, because that's my wife right there.
Yeah, I gave, like, explanation.
I don't know if you, like, explain the server stuff, so I...
Honestly, I'm just saying, ball.
Like, budget, we bought.
Fuck it.
Oh, I...
Whoa!
Wait, did you see the rule where we're supposed to put it on
email only mode when we start the game?
Are you going to do that?
I already did it, man.
Oh.
That's why they're in my chat talk.
That makes sense.
Because I didn't do it.
So yeah, for those who don't know.
we're supposed to put our chats at emote only mode um to
prevent people from cheating and ghosting and stuff but like
they said we can do it when the game starts the game hasn't
started yet that's the thing so yeah my mods it went the
moment the first round starts please put it at emote only
mode i'm not gonna forget so freaking good you're eating
your taco Yeah, I'll give you a taco.
Whoa!
In front of everybody?
What?
Yeah?
Yeah.
All right.
Should we go explore a little bit more?
Hey, there's Link.
Your taco?
You have one.
You have two hands.
One hand can eat the taco.
Okay, and then I'm taking a push-a-talk then.
Yeah, yeah, take voice activation.
Let them hear your voice.
What?
I'm on voice activation.
Let's go.
All right, let's go.
Wait, I should do voice activation too.
Let me...
Wait, how do I do this?
Press to disable...
Press to start recording.
How do I...
How do I do act?
Oh, there it is.
All right.
She's eating a taco.
Wait, Doki, look.
Mickey Mouse is my friend.
Oh, my God.
It's Mickey Mouse.
You got invited?
It's me, Mickey Mouse.
Oh, my.
What the hell?
Wait, that's so cool.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
This event is sponsored by Disney.
Okay.
That's insane.
I'm going to unmute myself.
am i muted sir am i good can you hear me oh no no how do i
oh wait it's okay oh okay i can hear yeah oh hello oh my god
it's so cool i can't believe it disney sponsored minecraft
yeah they did some people have an aura that's crazy no it's
not that that's bad you know the handle was just like i'm
like it it felt like she's eating a taco right now
i'm sorry for putting the lord's name in vain
Uncle Baby Billy Can people still hear me?
Yeah, yeah, we can hear Yeah Oh There's a cutscene Oh my god
1984 Oh my god The bite That's where Jossie was born The
bite of 1984
Hello everybody Welcome back to 5
How do we skip this cutscene?
We don't need lore?
Oh my god.
It's so elaborate.
It's okay, the round hasn't started yet, guys.
We're fine.
The moment the round started, then we do it.
Who are these people?
the thing is i don't know if these guys can hear me when i'm
talking right now because i have push okay i don't think
they can because no one said anything to me no one said like
shut shut the heck up so i assume nobody can hear me so i
had to pause and be like okay wait i can't swear yeah i'm
gonna probably say something I'm on voice activation because
I got lazy.
Oh my god, chicken.
Maplewood, town, September 3rd.
I have no idea what is going on.
Like, where did the haunted house come in?
Like, when does that come into play?
Oh, is that the house?
Oh, no, that's the house.
Okay.
Yeah, I know but like I'm just like thinking like oh my god.
This is like a Debut stream the lore video that's like 15 20
minutes long
We're watching a VTuber debut now
Oh, we're like news reporters they sent in like a hundred
and fifteen What the heck what is they sent in a hundred and
fifty news reporters to get to get in this Figure out what's
going on in the haunted house We need every angle Yeah,
always send it a hundred and fifty one of them will go viral
Okay, even like five news card wait is it like one person
per car?
Okay now that's excessive Each each news reported brought in
their own car
Who cares about global warming?
They don't know about carpooling.
The CO2 emissions go crazy.
Oh, what the heck?
There's ghosts?
Oh my god, it's so spooky.
Why are you here?
I'm here to report the news.
I'm here to represent BBC News.
Oh, there's 46.
Oh, sweet.
Four people already got eliminated.
I mean, it sucks for them, but...
Did you see that?
Four people already got eliminated?
I don't have permission to speak?
Yeah, guys, I don't have permission to speak.
silence Tokyo
no they actually silenced us oh we can talk now I can hear
you guys oh my god I thought they silenced us they just
trauma dumped on us yeah so are we like news reporters 150
news reporters I didn't wait to TV people.
I didn't wait to TV people.
Oh, my God.
It's like that.
If you guys want to see this hiding spot, I found.
Oh, yeah.
If you're the seeking, you can't.
It's like that Will Farrow movie where they send in all the
news reporters to fight.
It's just like that Will Farrow movie.
It's so dark up here.
Yeah, yeah.
If there's hide and seek, Gumi found the perfect spot.
They can't see us for very soon.
Whoa.
Oh!
Oh, no, I did have emotes-only mode!
Where are my mods?
Oh,
are you up there?
Oh, yeah, sure.
Yeah, of course.
Okay, but I'm, like, a baby, though.
So, wait, can I get promoted to wife number two if I play
Valorant with you?
You'll get promoted to my one and only one and only.
Okay, absolutely, then.
Okay, wait, I need to put mod-only mode.
How do I put mod-only mode?
Guys, I don't know how.
to do it yes wait wait emote okay i'm gonna message can you
help me put on emote only mode on my stream sorry caps it's
okay i personally messaged a mod to show up because i'm
still i'm a bit lazy yeah see yeah but what if you don't
make it to the round to do this.
Well, you guys are right on my legs.
We'll make it on.
Oh, yeah.
Fruit Bears, if you got to the finals, you got to split
60-40.
Wow.
It's going to be 60-20-20.
Oh, true.
60-20-20.
So I get 60 and you two get 20.
Got it.
Yeah.
So, like, if Fruit Bears win first place, and because we
showed him the God spot, um...
Yeah, that seems funny.
Yeah, I think I think that's pretty fair.
You have Minecraft money.
You don't you don't need 70,000 Yeah,
you got minecraft money I bet 70,000 dollars to you is like
is like an apple I mean It's a lot It's a lot of an apple
Dude, I just finished my two tacos.
It was so freaking good.
Oh Yum-bo what I guess- it's China is Sada tacos with salsa
verde and Oh, that sounds so good.
My goodness gracious I said like Are we are after two
minutes and 30 seconds?
Do we get like TP to the first game?
We die.
Okay, because I'm gonna be like it'll be a bit awkward if
like we're supposed to head to the place or something and
Maybe, maybe.
Because we're like, you have two minutes.
No, everybody's gone.
That's the spooky part.
Uh-oh.
Everybody's missing.
Oh, no, people are gone.
A lot of people are disconnected to fix their voice.
Oh, okay.
Oh, no, there's people up front.
Okay.
Nice.
Six people already got eliminated.
So, like, before the game's even started.
So we have a chance.
Yippee.
Yay!
What's the...
I feel like we should have the...
Oh yeah, yeah, we didn't get explored inside.
We only went to like one room.
I'm actually like lost.
We only explored one room and that was it.
Yeah, yeah.
That's not coffee.
What do you say hi to?
Oh my god, there's a skull.
Oh my god.
There's a couple of friends over there too.
Yeah!
I'm kind of scared.
Why don't we go in this room and our voices start lagging in
again?
Oh my god.
No, it's already starting.
Oh shit, it's so many people.
We gotta get our bandwidth back, Gumi.
We gotta get our bandwidth.
No, man.
It's Gumi.
Get that through your head.
Gumi and Gumi.
Yeah.
Two bears.
Look, it's two bears.
Oh my god, bears unite!
I'm a bear farmer.
Oh, what is it?
Oh, what did I just watch?
Yeah, farm bears.
I farm you.
Let's head over.
Let's go, Doki.
Get out of here.
Let's head over.
We gotta get our bandwidth back.
Alright guys, I still...
I still don't have...
I have zero mods on my...
It's an anarchy right now in my chat.
What?
None of the mods are online today for me.
That's crazy.
It's not looking so...
Oh!
Thank you!
We got ZZ!
Oh!
We're together!
Hold up my hand!
Oh!
Oh no
I'm scared
There's too many people I can't I can't tap out to do shimo
only mode Where?
Where's my mind?
I don't see it to me.
I'm scared.
I'm trying to find good.
Okay, I think I have time.
I have time to start email-only mode.
Email-only mode here.
If I tab out, I think I have time.
Okay, where was it?
Okay.
There you go.
No, I can't because I...
Oh, I'm not on this mod!
No!
Where are my mods?
Oh, no.
Wait.
The time started.
Oh, no.
Just...
I can't.
None of my mods are on.
Oh, no.
It started.
oh wait everything's quiet now oh thank god oh thank god but
where's goomy where's goomy she was gonna put me on her
backpack oh my mom is on i don't know where my mom was that
put it on but thank you we didn't we didn't get thank you oh
my god another bear my god bears unite
friends we're worse oh wait it's like four minutes until we
start i assume so right i assume it's like four minutes till
we start i hope so oh like did they did the voice chat just
got dc for everybody i think it did i think they shut down
the voice chat for everybody
Nobody's talking.
Oh my god.
I see a lot of like disconnected right now.
Can't have you guys tell me.
You guys can't tell me what's actually going on.
Because it's emote only.
I can't believe it.
Where people are.
Where are people at?
There's so many Minecraft skins.
There's no way 150 people are right here.
Right now.
That's a lot of people.
Oh my god, there's so many actual Minecraft players.
Because they have the Creeper Cape.
Right?
The Cape means that you are like an OG player, right?
I actually don't know.
I don't know much about like the Minecraft lore.
Wait, you guys can't even fact check me because you're all
on emote mode!
You guys can't...
I can't even get fact checked!
Because you're all on emote mode!
No!
That means I can say the most ridiculous things and nobody
can stop me.
Nobody can be like, I'm actually me.
Oh my gosh.
How do I fucking...
How do I fucking banter when my entire chat is just emojis?
Like, it's talking to a kindergartener.
Still trying to find people.
Wait, it just went back to five minutes.
It reset.
It reset itself.
I'm so confused.
I can't be like, hey guys, are people hearing anything on
like the other streams?
Or did everybody else's voice chat also crashed or like
doesn't work anymore?
I can't say, I can't ask you guys, but start where countdown
will restart once disconnected.
start where it left off oh oh so am i supposed to reconnect
because the voice chat's off oh maybe like oh maybe like it
crashed itself okay so do i have to reconnect i'm scared of
reconnecting i guess i can reconnect right i don't know i
don't know because you guys can't talk to me i don't know if
i should reconnect
Do I reconnect?
Yay for yet.
Log out.
Reconnect.
Nay for like.
Don't reconnect.
I mean.
Yay or nay guys.
I don't know.
I don't know what's going on.
Okay.
Please do not this.
Oh.
Okay.
Never mind.
Admin stopped.
Okay, JK, I don't need your help.
The admin stopped me before I could do anything.
Thank God.
I was about to do it.
There's just so many skins here.
I didn't realize there were a lot of bears.
There's actually a lot of big Minecraft players.
Isn't Tubbo like a really famous Minecraft streamer?
Oh, and I was just like, look at this guy.
I'm like trying to find.
Trying to find.
Oh, he is!
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
I'm a true Minecraft player now.
I'm basically a Minecraft player.
Is that Elmo in a fucking bikini?
But we can't say fuck.
We're allowed to have Elmo in a bikini, but we can't swear.
Like, I've been trying to find Kumi this entire time.
And I can't.
I found so many other people.
Oh, there's Rosentoodle.
I know her.
She's a V-Tuber.
Let's see.
I'm just slowly Moving through the queue Moving through the
queue Right now to see if I can find her Like I mean six
people have already Been eliminated so Wait no eight people
Right eight people have already been eliminated So like at
best Like as long as I'm not like Uh the 15 As long as I'm
not like as bad as Like 15 other players I should win this
Why are people in this corner like that's really it oh wait
oh my god I found her I did it guys we did it we found each
other now she can carry me I'm gonna use her I'm gonna use
her friendship with all the other Minecraft players to make
sure I don't die as well and I'm just the trophy wife
I'm the trophy wife, yeah
Goomy will save me Because all the other Minecraft players
would be like Oh my god Goomy, you're a friend So we won't
kill you And then they'll see me next to Goomy And they'll
be like Oh my god, you're Goomy's wife We won't kill you And
I'm like, oh thank god No, thank god protection by
association i'm gonna get protection here all right yay
should we be at the starting line come on goomy come on come
on we gotta go to the starting line goomy there's 40 seconds
left they're gonna have a head start goomy oh no come on
goomy I need the bodyguide protection.
Come on.
What are you doing?
Just standing there.
I don't know if they're going to TPS or not.
Oh no.
I don't know if they'll TPS.
I don't know if I should have to find her again.
What if I need to find her again?
It's so, like, what's the word?
It's so creepy when there's literally no sound.
Yeah, you know.
no sound at all and it's so fucking creepy
oh it's another cut scene let's fucking go to the house of
nightmares you all came here as journalists to test the
theories god we are news reporters you should now understand
that 150 news reporters and now it is you will be tested
representing bbc news put forth a series of challenging
nightmares each of which no i should be pbs kids for a
certain number of you should you fail representing pbs kids
remain in the house of nightmares forever look kids need to
have news reporters as well and your life depends on your
ability to succeed in lights out nightmare is called lights
out to survive you must traverse a long path to the safe
zone as you progress the lights will turn off and on
randomly when the lights turn off the spirits can see oh
that's why you have to stay still you can resume movement
once the lights come back on oh that's spooky you can find
ability boxes scattered around the environment what do the
boxes look like ability boxes will give you an advantage
over players.
The abilities could be a three second speed boost potion.
Oh, it is like Mario Kart.
Or a snowball that can freeze an opponent you hit for three
seconds.
It is basically like Mario Kart.
If you move while the lights are out, you will find yourself
haunted by the spirits.
I'm momentarily unable to move.
Okay, at least you don't die.
A timer will count down until you can move again.
This is a race to the safe zone Only 140 of you will pass
This means that 10 of you Will meet your final ending here
Oh wait That means two people will get eliminated Okay now I
don't want to jinx myself But like if I get I am one of the
two people that get eliminated I'm just never playing
Minecraft Yeah
I'm literally one of the two people I just get eliminated.
I'll be so fucking sad.
Literally.
Like there's 142 people.
And I'll be so, I'll be actually depressed if I get
eliminated.
Oh my god, please.
Don't let me be the two.
Don't let me be one of the two.
That's all I want.
I'll actually uninstall this game.
Then I became become one of them.
Oh my god.
30 seconds.
Whoa.
Oh my god.
They enabled voice chat again.
And then they disabled voice chat.
I like how they enabled voice chat.
Oh my god.
okay okay i don't like that i don't like that they should
have not enabled voice chat there when we're all okay okay
oh my i can barely see the light
oh oh oh no i can't see the Fucking light!
It's terrible!
Follow the crowd!
Okay,
that's fine.
Slowly passing by the people that got knocked out.
get fucked get fucked oh okay oh no don't talk please i'm
already overwhelmed i'm already overwhelmed and don't talk
guys don't talk
oh oh this is so scary oh my god this is so scary Can't see
anything!
Move away from me!
I can barely...
Oh god!
Move!
I can't see anything!
So I can't see the lights!
Oh god.
I need to like get away from everybody.
What the hell?
I need to make sure I'm not bunched up on people.
Because I really can't see anything.
Turn around.
No!
No, I see nothing.
Yeah, get fucked, loser.
I mean, get hacked, loser.
So once they don't know we'll take a ball.
Okay, we're okay.
Okay, there's no way we can be the bottom two.
We didn't get frozen once, guys.
There's no way.
There's...
Oh.
Oh, no, no.
We're like almost in the front of...
How are they faster?
I don't understand.
How are they so fast?
the people in the front like i'm we're moving the same speed
we're literally the same speed is there like a bunny hop
tank guys i can't even ask you guys if you know what the
bunny hop tank is because
what's the bunny hop what's the bunny hop tank he's god damn
minecraft players Okay, guys.
These goddamn Minecraft players and their B-hop tech.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, but there's a little shortcut here.
Don't go that way.
What do you mean?
Don't go.
Where do you go?
Where do you go, though?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
All right.
Follow the crowd.
Oh my gosh.
Still surviving.
I'm just like the Minecraft players.
I'm just like them.
Oh my god.
I should have been frozen.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god.
Guys, maybe I should be a Minecraft player.
Okay, I almost thought I got hit.
I almost thought I got hit.
Okay.
Nice.
we pass by people we pass yeah that's what you get for game
two coffee there i can't see i can't see oh i can't see it's
just names it's just names i can't wait i got blocked by 200
i got blocked by 200 people there Oh god, please, please,
don't mic spam.
Please, I beg of you.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
We're okay.
No, no, no, no.
What are you talking about?
Where is the safe zone?
How is it that far?
Okay.
There's still so much more than gold.
Yeah, really.
I could barely like take in the surrounding because it's
just people.
All I see are people.
Oh my god, all I see are people.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
We're almost there.
Oh, please, please don't.
Nice, nice.
actually don't even know we're almost there i i just feel
like i've been running forever chat i've been running for so
this is the front this is the front middle there's no way
there's nobody's at the same so not even the front of the
pack look behind i think this is the first 50 percent no but
like i nobody's at the same show yet okay
Please somebody hit the safe zone.
Please, I beg of you.
Somebody, please.
So I know what it's like.
So I know if the end is near.
That's all I want.
Is the end near yet?
Oh my god.
There's still people.
Because there's still more!
How the hell is there still more?
Wait, wait, wait.
All right.
Oh.
All I'm seeing is I haven't been hit once yet.
I haven't been hit by the ghost yet, guys.
I'm practically gaming.
Get shit on.
Look at all these people sitting down.
chill chill chill chill chill chill that's the only thing i
could hear oh my god they're so in the front oh i don't
understand how the moving thing like actually hits so i feel
like i should have been hit like several times oh god like i
like how nobody's getting the box or like the box Only the
front people can get the box right now.
So, like, I have not been hit once.
I have not hit the box once.
Lucky, I'm waiting last place right now.
Where are we?
Okay.
We have to be in the middle of the pack.
Yes!
I have not been on myself once.
Are you serious?
Oh, okay.
I'm too scared.
Too scared.
Oh, my God.
Now I know why.
Now I know why they're in the front.
Yes!
I'm speeding now!
God, she's...
Okay, I'm speeding, but yet she's still in the front.
Like, what is this fucking bullshit?
I know.
I'm speeding, yet I'm still not fasting.
Okay, I got a snowball.
Oh, my God, a snowball.
Did I hit...
No, I missed!
What is that really?
How do you...
You slowed me.
I have a crutch against you.
It wasn't me.
It didn't do anything.
It flew like...
I slowed me!
Okay.
Okay, they hid in those.
No, please.
Oh my god.
Please.
How is there still more?
do it first you do it first oh no there's still more of this
map
i don't i feel like i've been running for like 10 years we
do this i don't understand no one's at the safe zone
no but he's there oh my god i got frozen is this the safe
zone no it's not what the did you just hear that someone
says that you need to pick oh my god i'm shaking oh my god
my god my freaking heart oh my god i'm shaking too but it's
because of the comedy okay bro i'm just trying to exist i'm
just trying to exist guys i haven't been hit once
There's no way.
You're in my face, Kissy!
I have no idea.
Left or right.
Hurry, don't worry.
I'm going to go left.
Oh, Gus, Vic, where are you going?
Okay, I'm going left.
Okay.
I'm going left.
I trust left side.
Left side seems like they know what they're doing.
I trust the left.
That's a bad connotation.
Oh, please.
If it's not left, we're so fucked.
No, left or right, I hate making decisions.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait, I didn't even get that!
Who the heck got it?
I'm scared.
I'm so sad.
I got pinged so hard.
Where is the server?
The server is not on West Coast.
I got pinged so hard.
I hit somebody.
Okay, nice.
All right.
This is not fair.
This is the ping diff.
The ping diff mess me over.
Goodbye.
Oh.
Dude, I messed up.
I messed up.
All right.
Please.
The moment I see people leading into the safe zone, I know
the moment.
The moment I know it's almost over.
It was out of panic.
Hi, Lexi.
We're still okay.
Lexi Murphy.
Okay, not gonna lie, we should eliminate more than 10.
Guys, are we in the bottom of the pen, be honest?
This should have been like, oh, this should have been like
20, like, at least.
30 people.
Oh god, I thought that was a ghost.
That's just Tubbo.
Okay.
There we go.
Come on, come on, please.
Hi, DC.
No, that's not the plan.
Are we done yet?
Smile run N.
We're just journalists.
They're not supposed to be running!
It's not water!
What the fuck?
How much more of this do we have to do?
Well, there's a box that is not for me, I guess.
Don't get near the person with the box.
Don't scream me, don't freeze me, I'm just a girl.
There's no way.
We must be top 50.
There's no way!
I didn't get stopped once!
Come on, bro.
We can do this, we can do this, we can do this, we can do
this.
I'm dead, I'm dying.
I feel like, I feel like I've seen this place like 20 times.
I'm actually going to poop my pants.
I feel like I've looked at the same hallway.
Bye, Tomo.
Don't wait for me.
Don't squeeze me.
I don't know.
Wow.
See me.
Hey, Flick!
Someone please.
Chop this mansion in half, please.
We're like all the way in the front, dude.
Yeah, that's crazy.
Chop this mansion in half for the love of God.
There's still no one safe.
Okay, okay.
Pigeon me!
There's no one fucking safe!
What the heck?
If nobody in the front is safe, that means there's so
much...
Oh no!
There's so much more!
There's so much more energy!
Yeah,
we got this!
Everything's fine.
Oh!
Oh god.
This is it.
Please.
Somebody!
Hey Jack!
You're back in peace?
I'm gonna go crazy!
How are we not done with that?
We're winners!
That's all I would!
Leave me out!
Be sure!
Thank you for the false hope, I appreciate it regardless.
me finish this race wait did i got haunted was that hot
who's that no that wasn't oh my god someone just fucking
showed up in front of me i was like what the fuck is that
i'm just a girl i'm just a beautiful okay oh nice we're okay
we're still okay i'm so far behind you're not far behind we
haven't been stopped once there's no way we're behind
there's no way we're one of the two that gets eliminated
guys i didn't realize how big this mansion really is guys
like i'm already my energy's gone already
as an introvert i'm putting in a room filled with 150 people
and having to run and hear You're so many.
I mean, you're the person in front of me, like, you've been
thrown down this video.
You guys, hearing all these voices are like 10, 15 minutes
straight and ready.
I am already fucked up.
Oh, I'm done.
Or you could go for like a Hail Mary throw it like throw it.
Oh my god, there's a checkpoint!
What the fuck does a checkpoint?
like what do you mean check point three there's no fucking
way i can't believe it why would you fall off there's it's a
bridge how can you fall off from this oh god okay now i'm
scared okay now i'm scared a little bit because i said that
all right the moment i see one of 140 i know it's over i'm
i'll be free the moment the moment i see one out of 140 i
know Freedom is so close.
Freedom will be there.
Oh my god!
We're doing a Minecraft Witch Rivals, but I'm already so...
My mental is already so...
I've been running this course, I feel like, for like 15
minutes straight right now.
We have to put out Emo-only mode, because they're worried
that people are going to go because there's 150 players and
first prize is like 70 000 so that we have to have eva only
mode but right now right oh shit nice oh my god fuck you you
missed your shot he's in front of me how do you how do i
miss something point blank twice
it landed there's no fucking way There's no fucking way I
missed twice.
Oh my god.
Two out of a hundred checkpoints.
Nice.
Two out of a hundred.
We're doing it guys.
All right.
We're ready.
DQ them.
Here we go.
Please.
Someone please.
Take me out of this misery.
VAR.
Can we get some VAR on that?
All right, here we go.
Yo, yo, yo, yo.
Where are we?
I wish there was a map.
Like, there's so many things in this Minecraft thing, but we
don't have a map.
That's the only thing we're missing is a goddamn map, so I
know how far we have left.
That's all I want.
Wouldn't be funny, I've been, like, open mic this entire
time.
There's no way.
purposely made sure I was pushed to talk it was so funny
I've been like annoying like 140 people with me ranting
about this there's no way there's no way nobody could hear
hear my cries of pain except for you guys oh god we're so
close I said that 10 minutes ago but we're so close guys
We're so close, guys.
I swear.
We're so close.
I got the speed.
It's fine.
But yet, for some reason, she's so faster than me.
Oh!
Oh my god!
There's hope!
Guys!
Oh my god!
How far ahead is that?
this man bro this guy is first place and nobody else has
made it yet
oh my god there's hope there's hope we're so close there's
hope i
like how everybody who's made it are just minecraft players
guys that that 70k is going to a minecraft player guys it's
not going to a regular player like me We did it.
We did it.
Don't go.
Oh, my God.
We got this.
We're so close.
We're almost there.
We are talking.
Oh, when it's going so fast?
Oh.
Guys, I'm scared now.
It's going so fast.
Guys, it's going so fast, guys.
Guys.
Oh, God.
There's no way.
Oh, guys, I'm scared.
I'm actually scared now.
Oh, wait.
Okay, it's right there, bro.
We got this.
Is that the end?
Oh, my God.
Is that it?
I didn't realize how far back I was.
Oh, please.
We're so close.
Oh, my God.
Please.
I just did it!
Oh, thank God!
I thought I'm down in the stars!
Help!
I muted everybody!
Please.
Oh, God, thank God.
all right unemo mode guys we did it oh wait is my mod still
around unemo mode how do i unemo mode you can remove emo
mode now how was i 97.
i thought like i i thought i was doing pretty well i didn't
get stopped at all how the was i 97.
i swear like okay at least I don't have to uninstall this
game.
I'm not one of the two people.
Oh, I'm not one.
One of the two people that got eliminated.
Just so you guys know, two people will be eliminated in this
game.
And I said I said I would never play Minecraft again if I
was that unfortunate.
Oh my god.
I'm happy.
I'm so happy.
Jesus Christ.
I hope you guys could hear me with all the people talking.
I couldn't even tell you guys could hear me.
There was just too much dialogue.
Too many people were talking.
Oh my god.
I like, oh no, I'm stuck.
I was like so overwhelmed.
I came in here.
Lots of energy.
Lots of energy prepared for this event.
150 people started talking.
And now I'm out.
all that energy gone oh my god all right who's gonna be
eliminated anyway I wonder who's gonna make it the battery
yeah Gumi apparently made it I saw someone said in chat she
made it I don't see her though I turned off the voice chat
because it was just too much like 150 people in this room
Gumi was top 20 a minecraft player though she actually plays
minecraft like i'm not surprised my best bet is i don't
because the next game the next game is um is uh pvp it's a
1v1 um it's a 1v1 and like i'm so fucked if like uh i'm
against an actual minecraft player it's like some goddamn
pvp shit all right guys also like i stopped caring about the
swear reel like they're not gonna check this vibe right as
long as i'm not swearing in other people's streams like guys
we all know i'm not gonna make it to fucking top 20 guys i'm
here for the content yeah 150 people and i'm the only one
swearing like that i call that bullshit like i believe the
minecraft players wouldn't the minecraft players will follow
the rules like we'll follow the rules but the non-minecraft
players like me would definitely not be following oh wait
one more person oh okay yay we did it 140 players oh no
tiffany whoever you are no leifison whoever you are I don't
know who you are.
No, Sofitty.
Rest in peace.
I don't know who you are.
But, oh no, wait, that's a V-Tuber.
Oh no!
Project...
Oh, is that Project Melody?
Oh no!
Melody!
Oh no, don't worry.
I'll carry on the banner.
The V-Tuber banner.
Rosadoodle.
I think Rosadoodle.
still in too don't worry we'll get eliminated the next game
instead
oh oh okay now i can i should be able to oh my god we woke
up i just woke up from my nightmare we gotta find people i
know you're top five on the minecraft category oh god oh god
please don't don't have zero expectations please please have
zero expectations on me i'm not i'm not like your other
minecraft players i don't know what i'm doing i found this
guy like i was 97th in the race guys Oh, no, no, that means
children are watching!
Alright, kids, if you're watching me and you have Twitch
Prime, don't worry, your mom will have Twitch Prime.
Why did y'all go so fast?
Oh, no, I can't believe it.
The Minecraft kids are watching me now.
Minecraft children, let me introduce you to better games.
Alright, for all those who are new here, I actually usually
stream on YouTube, but because this was a Twitch Rivals,
Twitch Rivals tournament, that's why I'm the Twitch, but
yeah, please check me out on YouTube if you enjoyed this
content.
I barely could take in this entire mansion, because all I
did was just run.
You scratched my CD.
Oh, sorry.
What the fuck?
Okay, I don't know what's going on with that girl My
goodness I didn't even get a chance to like actually take in
the mansion builds Because I swear I was just like I swear I
was just like I feel like I feel like I should have died
like people are just like in my space i couldn't even see
what was going on spania yeah there's like a lot of um
spanish-speaking streamers in this tournament too because uh
minecraft's really popular oh wait that's that's her again
every time i bump into her she's eating oh yeah no i was
frozen and the lights were off i never got a chance to get
hung by the ghost and I still can't believe it I never got I
never got haunted by a ghost but yet what the fuck I never
got haunted by the ghost but I'm still 97 like what is the
tech no what what the heck is the tech I just how do you go
so fast this guy is Reggie I just you run you run and hold
space oh you don't manually jump you just let the jumping
wait is that it you hold space oh i've been manually jumping
by the way i've been i've been manually pressing the jump
that's how you do the buddy half i i just been like i've
been doing this oh oh oh
yeah i didn't well now i know now that i know it's over it's
over we're gonna be so well okay look people don't hold hold
buttons in fps game okay that's a lie because we need a
right click oh we hold the right click but like not for
jumping okay guys i don't know you guys know this but in
like shooter games we don't jump a lot because when you jump
you're more predictable I didn't know the tech.
You keep acting as if we've never been.
Oh my God.
You know, you know when he said that OVO is like working.
At least like not a lot of people got eliminated though.
Oh my gosh.
I just I've been with the mob of people and I saw the mob of
people go right and I was like, okay.
I wonder like, I wonder if like right was faster than left
though.
I wonder.
This is a lot.
I got slowness of my sapnap as well.
It was the little girl.
This is a very long intermission.
Take us to the second game.
Wait, I have an egg.
It clearly shows that it was an accident.
There was, I have an egg on my bottom right.
What's that?
Yeah, his eyes actually.
Oh my god, where's Gumi?
Where's Gumi?
Playing Apex Minecraft now.
I mean, there's Roblox Apex.
I don't know if you guys ever seen it.
watch Roblox just just because I was curious guys stream
snip for me where's grooming would you want to alliance with
me guapo and erob wait it's a winning team I swear are you
sure what if we get eliminated how can we get eliminated we
have erob oh that wait but no that's why we're gonna get
eliminated don't Why are you made by that?
Don't listen to her, Yerav.
It's okay.
He didn't lose the last run.
He made it before the seven people that got eliminated.
Okay, what's the placement?
What did Yerav place?
We don't have to talk about that.
Yerav, what did you place, Yerav?
As long as you qualify.
What did you place?
I was like 10 behind you or like 8 behind you or something.
Because I...
Yeah, I had a wooden...
102 is nice.
Are you supposed to be nice be nice So are you joining us or
nah Okay Sure sure I'll join your alliance Okay so Do you
know the next game?
It's like some 1v1 shit right?
Wait Doki what did you get?
Definitely not 102 Okay what did you get though?
Because I didn't see you up front I was top 100 Just so you
know Like, how top 100 were you?
Like, top 100, it counts.
It's below EROB.
Okay, so double digits, but like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Double digits.
That's all you need.
It's not...
It's a two-view, not three-view.
Okay.
So, in a 1v1, do you beat EROB?
Be honest.
Yeah.
I think so.
I think so, too.
Yeah.
Do you even play Minecraft?
No, no, no, no.
Don't get me to play Overwatch.
Don't get me cracked.
Okay, Overwatch is...
minecraft yeah but you don't even play minecraft i've beaten
the game on hardcore that's great that's it good for you i'm
proud of you man that's so good have you bro how minecraft's
been out for like 20 plus years like you beat hardcore
minecraft yeah i beat minecraft hardcore like when i was
like 13.
oh man We're a team guys, we're a team.
That laugh is so toxic.
Hey, Steve with eight out of two nights coming through,
watch out.
Eight out of ten.
Wait, it took you three years on stream to beat Minecraft
hardcore?
No, it took me like two months.
You could not force that out of me.
I believe in this team.
This next game is about lying.
So like...
Oh.
Everyone's muted.
Maybe there's like eggs up here.
Alright.
Yeah.
We'll win, right guys?
Have you been?
Yeah.
We'll totally win.
What's the 15 incident?
What my chat are asking?
Okay.
Don't keep no.
No.
you can ask that.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yeah, I believe.
I believe in this team.
Wait, so what is this?
What is the second game?
I didn't really understand it.
I think I'll tell us.
Yeah, we'll get a video that even E-Rob can understand.
Oh, okay, sweet.
Nice.
As long as he understands, our team will be solid.
Yes, did you read the rules, though?
It's in the daily itinerary.
Yeah, I read the rules.
I just didn't really understand the game.
Yeah, I don't really understand.
Yeah, I was just like, what?
The lying thing?
You get one of the three.
So it's like rock, paper, scissors, but like, oh, I have
rock and I have to like lie or betray.
Yeah, so it's just like among us or something.
So it'd be like, I- Yeah, it's kind of like playing
Overwatch and only playing ball.
And then if you get counterfeit, you complain.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it's your fault.
I paid 40 to only know it's free to play now.
I paid $40 for this Hammond skin.
I should be allowed to play Hammond.
Yeah.
All right, guys, I believe in this team, guys.
picked his though guapa said he's blade and he's refusing to
swap so like i don't know yeah i'm blade but there's only
three so we don't have yeah check these two rooms i didn't
see any one two three yeah i mean like hi mendo i don't know
where they are i know there's one you made it too what okay
okay do you want to guess what this guy don't you what
number did you get because
you.
I said top 100.
That's all that matters.
You weren't lying, I guess.
It is top 100.
I think it was pretty close.
Yeah.
What were you?
I got like 20 or 30 or something.
You can't say that.
You got 102.
You made it.
Was that you at the finish line?
I was sitting there.
Yeah.
Okay.
Somebody was like, Sasha, you're gonna make it.
All right.
That was me.
Okay.
I thought so.
I was yelling for E.
he actually yeah it's okay it was so nice as long as we're
below erob see i was trying to grease people up front i was
getting all the snowballs and stuff i am i didn't get like
caught by the girls at any point except for right in front
of the finish line because i tried to get greedy i got
caught 100 it's caught 100.
you can't take that from me i got caught like three times
to the next game yeah me too i'm shaking my boots i don't
want to lie i didn't know how to jump too i think it's like
wait let's go look for easter eggs it's like rock paper
scissors
hey guys it's going to be playing fucking pokemon right now
it's not rock paper scissors what do you mean no that's
that's everything i relied on the internet that's like rock
paper scissors guys if it's not like rock paper scissors and
what do i do wait is that one over here like we got like
what do i do if it's not like rock paper scissors oh she's
at the freddies yeah yeah i'm heading over i'm heading over
let's see all the different minecraft skins wait this is not
this is not it I feel like I wouldn't even understand the
Easter eggs because I feel like it's gonna be Minecraft
related And I'd be like the fuck is that sorry the heck is
that It's the orange guy it's the orange guy orange guy
where is the fanat.
Oh, it's over here I love looking at the like she moved to
the bedrooms.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I just wanted to say hi
I can't believe I have to do like this merry-go-round the
webcam
which bedroom there's like 20 bedrooms which one's the right
bedroom she's running down oh my god oh my god where the
heck is she where is she I can't believe it guys look at me
can you tell i'm holding space jump now look i would have
been way ahead if i knew about the space holding space tech
if i if i knew the holding space tech i would have been
first place easy i was literally nerfed and still got top
500 guys i i was nerfed so hard Wait, Gumi!
There's two, there's two, there's two.
Gumi!
Dude, I saw you made it!
I was waiting for you!
I was so scared.
I was like number 97, but I was top 100.
I didn't like...
I got 22nd.
I was surprised.
I didn't realize you're supposed to hold spacebar.
I was manually jumping.
Do you know what?
I thought that.
I was like, damn.
She probably doesn't know.
how to sprint jump yeah i was just like how are they so fast
i'm doing the same thing as them and then people were like
you're supposed to hold space apart when you're jumping it's
great because i didn't get hit by the ghost too i never got
hit by the ghost but so far behind i was so confused i did i
got right behind you are you looking for the easter eggs no
No, I'm just chilling.
I was talking to, like, Mendo and E-Rob earlier.
Oh, really?
Yeah, because they wanted to do an alliance and stuff.
Because, like, it's...
They're saying, like, this one's, like, a rock, paper,
scissors.
The next game.
And, like, it's all about, like, lying and stuff.
Yeah.
But what happens if you guys go against each other then,
Wendoki?
Then, like...
Then, I guess the alliance is over.
What happens if we go against each other, Gumi?
60-40 like I'll give you I'll give you 60 if you let me I oh
yeah you can take 40 yeah yeah yeah if I if you let me win
right because that's how much you love me right yeah you
wouldn't lie to me like that right no I wouldn't do I look
like a man to you oh that
who hurt you you know who you know every single one of my
exes you literally know every one of my exes
what do you mean who hurt me you know 1x 2x 3x 4 red fish
blue fish and purple
There's no eggs, man.
What are the Easter eggs supposed to...
Oh, is that what the eggs are in the bottom, right?
Yeah.
Hey, anyone seen an egg ever?
Wait, but what do we get if we get all the eggs?
They're the TVs.
They're the televisions.
Oh.
You have to punch the televisions on the floor.
But what do we get if we get the Easter eggs?
Do we get like $1,000?
We get $1,000.
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Oh, Tucky, come here.
Okay.
Here, let's do this real quick.
I don't know, I'm on your own as well.
Fine, we're clutchable, clutchable.
Oh, where's the car?
V and then settings and then turn 3D voice to reduced.
Oh, 3D audio?
Yeah, 3D audio to reduced.
Oh, oh shit.
That might help a bit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Emo and only trash.
No, Minda, what do we do?
What do we do?
Oh, wait.
Emo only chat.
I got some of the Easter eggs.
All right.
How many?
Yeah, how many?
There's three in this corridor.
I got seven.
There's one on the outside.
I'm nine.
Hortyard.
Where's where?
Can you take me there?
So how this alliance is going to work?
Seven seconds left.
Yeah.
All right.
Good luck, everybody.
Good luck.
I'm blinking.
I'm blinking, too.
Hold me, don't get me.
Hold on, my hand.
Oh, no.
Emo it only.
Thanks, guys.
Oh, it's like a carnival.
Oh, my God.
It's this.
Disneyland!
This is why Mickey's here!
It's a carnival?
This is exactly why Mickey was here.
It's like an amusement park.
I don't know.
I don't think he should draw the game.
Wait, yo, VTMC.
VTMC.
Hey, what's up, what's up, what's up?
I saw E-Rob.
You got this, bro.
Best of luck.
I'm scared, guys.
I'm so scared.
I don't understand this game at all.
I don't understand this game.
It's not as overwhelming as the first game, that's for sure.
Oh my god, it's Elmo in a bikini!
Here's Elmo!
In a bikini!
Where's my squad eye bro?
Yeah, where's my alliance?
Where the heck is my alliance?
Come on, come on.
Come on, guy.
How am I supposed to survive without my allies?
How would I survive?
They will play five games.
Four rounds each.
One versus one.
No!
Oh my god, that's so loud.
I've never seen somebody so sad about rock paper scissors
holy fuck the guy was full on despair like what the rock
paper scissors do to that man you know how many people are
getting eliminated right now 30 I'm gonna be in that three
guys there is like a 50 50 there's like 80 83 a 20 chance
I'm in that 30 that's the Non-Minecraft player.
I'm so fucked.
This was...
Non-Minecraft player here.
I'm actually fucked, guys.
How is the game volume loud?
Oh my god, the ambient voice.
It's so loud.
The music.
Where's my ally?
groups Where's my ally group?
There's so many other Moncrafters here, but not the ones I
want to find It's not the fucking fighting gameplay Oh my
god, this is like the The crossover of the century Just know
A Spanish streamer told me Argentina sauce I don't I didn't
know there was Oh my god, I was looking for you.
Stop streaming.
Where the fuck is going?
Two more minutes, guys.
Two more minutes.
Why am I stressed out?
I know I'm not gonna make it.
I shouldn't be stressed out about this.
We all know I'm not gonna make it to the end.
We saw the top 20 in the fucking running course.
Jesus Christ.
That should not be that loud.
Like I do not care about the ambience.
They're just, these are the gap.
Oh, please give me my cutscene.
Oh, wait, what's this?
Are these the balloons?
Oh, they're like balloons.
that made this world it's actually insane though the team
that made this world it's so it's so good do you really want
to be with i really i just love like all the builds and
everything the aesthetics and stuff of everything like the
world building it's actually insane wait there's more
there's an outside
Oh my god.
There's an outside.
I think it's like rock, paper, scissors.
But you get like one of the three.
Alright.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
It's a deserted circus.
What the hell?
Where are the clowns at?
Where are the killer clowns?
Oh wait, you can't even get up here.
Fucking scam.
Holy shit.
is a circus for giants like what the fuck this area is
actually huge i'm scared why do we need such a big arena for
rock paper scissors i don't i don't understand if it's rock
paper scissors then like why do we need such a big area a
cage would work
just put us in a fucking cage all right off we go off we go
see what's so embarrassing is I actually have played rust of
course I didn't know that oh my god I'm still like oh skull
scroll blade oh this skull I assume is rock paper scissors
it's funny that we have a copyright free version of rock
play congratulations to those who made it through lights out
the next nightmare will be a more intimate affair you will
soon divide yourselves into five groups of 28 players each
the conjurer warns that people in your group will be your
opponents so choose carefully within your groups you will be
randomly pitted against different players for five matches
of skull scroll and blade each match will consist of four
rounds where do i keep choosing skull to win a round skull
beats blade blade beats scroll and scroll beats skull each
round begins with one of the two players being assigned an
item a skull a scroll
player may chat with their opponent to try and figure out
what item they were assigned.
Oh!
So they can choose an item to beat it.
Be wary of deception here.
The fuck?
This is gaslighting.
Player two will select an item in their hotbar and a winner
will be revealed.
Winning a round earns you two points and losses earn you
zero.
If both players draw the same item, there will be a
tiebreaker a red button will appear in the center of your
table and the first one to click in what the that's the
tiebreaker across the five matches and at the end of the
nightmare the six players with the fewest points in each
group will be oh my god those six that's gonna be me this
means that today that's that's so stressful oh my god guys
it was a good rush guys
I'm not a liar.
It's so I can't believe it.
I can't lie guys.
I'm not known as a liar You can't hear the sound.
I don't know why it's playing on a different thing.
Okay, I need a recap Oh my god, it's gonna be so difficult.
I'm so bad at lying
I can't believe it.
I'm such a I'm a good person forced to lie and gaslight
people i don't know what curry is it's gonna be locate the
walk talk to others oh we we rip it we rip it we rip it oh
it was over here we gotta go to the circuit the person to my
left always tells a lie all right there you go we found the
circus hey it's a me is a gabagool
the circus how do i i'm like trying to think how to
yes keep ordering their uber eats right now farm of john
farmer john why are like intruding on a date i'm just this
third wheel is listening to their pasta order
Just like, what the hell?
Oh, hey!
Goody!
There you are!
Here I am.
This game is going to be so difficult.
Oh, you DMed me?
Yeah, I just saw them.
Oh!
Oh, yeah, yeah, I saw it.
Yeah, yeah, I saw them earlier, too, in the first round.
Monk dog.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
Don't get eliminated.
Protect me.
Don't worry.
I'll protect you.
Oh, my God.
this game is going to be so difficult because like you have
to lie and i don't i'm i'm not always tell the truth shut up
shut up what do you mean stop talking it is so difficult
wait wait wait we're going to form an alliance right yeah
yeah yeah so like when you fight me let me win because you
know i'll lose i'll get kicked out Whoever has less points.
Yeah, yeah, but you'll let me farm points off of you, right?
Hello.
Well, only if I have more points than you.
Yeah, yeah.
And you'll always have more points than me.
You're a Minecraft player.
Girl, this game ain't got nothing to do with Minecraft.
You're a Minecraft.
Yeah, people trust you.
People don't trust...
And people also trust me, too.
But, like, I'm just way too trustworthy.
Don't trust me.
You don't need to farm points off of you, right?
You let me farm points off of you.
Right?
If I get eliminated, who will bring the content?
I have bad luck, but I only have good luck when it doesn't
matter.
It's okay.
All right.
When you're up against me, just pick Blade.
Okay.
I'm just every time you pick Blade.
I'm going to pick.
Yeah, yeah.
Pick Blade.
The biggest brain.
Wait, Gumi, what is it?
What is it, Gumi?
oh wait she's afk never mind it's okay guys we got this guys
gumi will let me farm points off of her so i won't be bottom
six guys of 28 people there's no way there's no way of 28
people i refuse to be the worst player right channeling all
of my lucky charms i had in my cereal last week yeah yeah
just pick blade when you're up against me just pick blade
what happened to yeah yeah yeah you're gonna pick blade like
the big brain move pick blade what if you have scroll what
if you have scroll there's no way there's no I'm telling I
don't lie I tell the truth just pick blade you don't even
know you're lying to yourself that's why I told you pick
blade you can't pick skull you get No, no, I get three.
No, they said they give you three and you get the pick.
That's if you're opposing them.
That's if you're opposing, if you're the opposing side.
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
Okay, so there's two people sitting at the table, yes?
Yeah.
There's two people sitting at the table.
One of them, you don't know who you are, but one of them
gets given a randomized scroll blade or skull.
And the other person has to guess which one that person got.
Only one person gets to choose.
That's not both of them.
Wait, my whole plan!
My whole plan!
I'm gonna take that as a yes you.
Okay, okay, when you're up against me, I will always tell
the truth, Gumi.
You'll tell me, you'll tell me, yeah.
I'll always tell the truth, and you'll let me farm off of
you so I won't get eliminated.
Yeah, you're gonna tell?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yo!
Hey!
oh my god my entire plan it's over it's so over it was just
not clicking in your hand you're like what i thought it was
just regular rock paper scissors
are you going into our lobby do you trust us yeah wait how
do we pick colors in the circus oh you see around the map
listen listen no no listen yeah we legit we can team up
Okay, like, we don't know who we'll play against.
It's 28 people per lobby.
Yeah.
We can farm each other.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
There's a text.
There's a text that the Minecrafters were telling me.
Yeah?
They were telling me.
Okay, what was it?
Basically, you make an alliance, and in your alliance, if
you go against each other, whoever has more points, they
lose on purpose to the person who has less points.
To even it out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can say that in more complex words, though.
Oh!
Wait, what color?
Oh my God, we're in fighting these lights!
Wait, wait, what color?
Boost me, boost me!
Boost me!
Duffy, Duffy!
I'm not lost!
Let's go this way.
Shut up, Slippy!
Where do we go?
I'm so confused!
Oh my God, Slippy's making me confused!
E-Rob!
Where do we go?
Which color?
We got a group.
Where's Abe?
Abe got lost in the massacre!
Where's Guapo, man?
We all got lost!
Go in there!
Go in the pink!
Oh no, this is already over.
Oh god, they're filling up guys.
They're filling up real quick.
Oh, we have to pick one color.
We gotta choose!
We can't pick pink!
Oh, there's Abe!
There's Abe!
Blue, Blue, Blue, Blue, Blue, Blue, Blue, Blue, Blue, Blue,
Blue, Blue, Blue, Blue, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Blue is filling up though!
What if we don't make it?
Yeah, what if we don't make it?
We have to split up.
Okay, we split.
I'll see you on the other side.
Okay.
All right, we're good.
We're fine.
How many people?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What if I want to leave?
Wait, what if they have a bigger team?
It's not gonna smoke me.
I'm picking rock.
Hey, hey, hey.
Get in here.
Get in here, baby.
This is my favorite.
Oh my god.
You can be.
You can be mentally fortified.
I'm not going to change the fact that I'm picking wrong.
Wait, Gumi, what are you doing?
Sleepy.
What are you doing?
What are you picking?
I'm scared.
Get on the platform.
You're not, you're not fortified as I am.
Gumi, Gumi left!
You, what?
Where did Gumi go?
Yeah.
Gumi, Gumi, are you not doing...
Yeah?
Oh, what?
You're right.
He's right.
Sleepy.
Use two of your brain cells.
Hey, what the heck was that?
Who hit me?
Hey, hey, buddy, I'm letting you down.
Hey, look what you're looking at, guys.
Oh, yeah, we could stay here.
We could stay here.
Don't stop hitting each other.
Hey, hey.
I need Reggie.
You've thought, you've thought about it.
Oh!
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
We're cool.
I don't know if you're whispering about something, but I
can't hear you.
I'm just saying we're good.
We're good.
We're cool.
Are we cool?
We're so cool.
What?
I think the other groups have bigger alliances in us.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
We got this.
Are you in?
I feel like I know too many people.
Don't get knocked out.
It's almost full.
Okay, I feel like I have two people in here.
Oh, but you're back in!
Hey, we're team!
We're team!
No team!
I'm a little scared!
Sleepy, sleepy, sleepy!
I got brain!
Oh, they're kicking people out!
They're kicking people out!
You've seen Mark me like 20 times in a row.
Okay, bro, listen.
One we match up against each other.
I need to decide how many wins and must win out.
I got five!
I know you're trying to do this.
I'm scared of getting knocked out.
I'm scared of getting locked up.
there's a tool yeah i'm gonna read their minds bottom in
your group yeah i'm gonna crunch the numbers and do the math
yeah samuelson you're gonna do all that whoa whoa i'm not
samuelson i'm sam's little brother right now so loud oh
what's your name yeah what oh mine okay my name's uh little
sam i don't know little sam i mean regardless this is up
there this is up the chance anyway yeah it doesn't it
doesn't get any better in the first game he had to throw me
on a bunch of faces we recognize oh also i'm not gonna lie
don't get kicked out the other teams we haven't checked out
are all gonna have like hbg like a bunch of them oh yeah
yeah i know i know i'll do the same thing it depends i do
the same thing according to the mathematics you should you
should average one point per game so if you're like 10 games
in you should have around 10 points
You know what I mean?
Because two for win, zero for loss.
Doki, yeah?
Doki, there's a common evil.
There's a common evil.
It's okay.
If you're not at once on games, come on.
Yeah, yeah, then it's.
Yeah.
It's.
As long as you're getting something.
Is it?
We have to make sure the women win.
I'm just saying that that should be the metrics.
Oh, okay.
You and I are both women.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that means you gotta make sure I live through the path
next round.
You gotta make sure.
I don't.
Girl, you can make sure of yourself.
No, no.
This is a group effort.
Go see.
This is a group effort, Goobie.
Oh, I'm nervous.
Hey!
I forgot.
I forgot that it actually hits.
Oh, my God.
That's fucked up.
That's messed up.
I did not need to hit you.
I'm sorry.
Oh, emo only.
Don't worry.
You have emo only.
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
Because you win, I win, okay?
Okay, we can fortnight.
Oh, gosh.
I'm thinking, guys, when we face each other, do not draw.
I told everybody I'm going to be completely honest.
You want the most...
Oh, goodbye.
Why do you get kicked up before the round starts?
We have one minute aim to get in here.
Yeah, you won't, you won't, you won't?
Like, if I'm going online.
I miss it.
It gets kicked out.
You see it's not in.
One minute left, Dave!
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
No, no, no, no, no!
Give me!
His name is like, Oh, yeah.
Three!
It'll be like a freeway!
People be living here to keep out!
We're kicking you off the team, Ava.
Yeah!
What happened to you?
Yeah, that's why we're trapping you out.
And A's not in the circle.
Oh, Ava, you're being sacrificed.
Good luck, Ava.
50 seconds!
You're gonna front you up.
If it's me, let's get in!
Oh shit!
Free e-limp!
Holy shit!
I better hope you're not going up against.
Oh shit!
Well... well...
Hello!
So...
You probably want to know know what item i was assigned
don't you yeah yeah i mean you wouldn't lie to me right
wouldn't you like to know i love to know all right five
gifted subs if you tell me what you have right now i
actually developed a strategy you gotta listen to the
mathematics okay okay i'm listening so on average if you get
at least one point a game you should be fine but the outcome
out of each round um is usually two points unless we draw
and If we draw, then the outcome is one point's net.
So if we just trade wins, then...
Yeah, oh, that's so smart.
Yeah, yeah, you want to do that?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
You cooked me.
Sorry.
Can you explain again?
You actually want to do that.
No, I got confused.
I got confused.
We trade wins.
So you won the first one.
Yeah.
So then I let you win the next one, right?
Yes, and then you win the one after that, and then I win
that one after that.
And then I guess the last one will just end up to chance.
Okay, that sounds fun.
Okay, I'm so serious about this too.
I'm so serious.
Yeah, yeah.
Tell me what you have.
I will let you win again.
And then...
To like give my...
You let me build my trust?
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, okay, I have a blade.
I'm so serious.
you do you actually have yeah why would i lie to you i'm so
serious i'm so serious if you lie this is actually messed up
okay oh my god wait you lied to me okay i forgot i forgot i
was letting you win okay oh wait oh okay i i i actually
didn't even i have paper i have paper you have paper yes i
actually have paper i'm not trolling you actually not
trolling so yes i have paper so you go knife okay yeah yeah
right that's how you go but like what do you lie to me i'm i
swear to you i'm not lying i know i just tricked you but i
swear i'm actually just an idiot earlier that means you were
purposely tricking me i i'm actually just dumb wait so like
oh now you're just dumb oh i see i'm actually just dumb i
have paper though oh okay so like do we just wait well you
choose you choose knife right yeah does that knife oh you
did have paper oh you don't trust me huh i mean you didn't
trust me too i'm actually an idiot i actually messed it up
the second time you messed it up the second time like what
do you mean by that No, like, on round two, I'm...
No, wait, no, I'm round...
I don't even know.
I don't know.
You know what?
Let's just make it...
Let's make it special.
Let's not... I won't even tell you what I have.
Because I actually didn't look, so...
I don't even know what I have.
Okay.
Yeah, what could...
It could have worked together.
This could have been fine.
I mean, I did try to work together with you, but you didn't
even...
You tricked me.
I will give you this one if you tell me what you have.
What I have?
i think i had paper i think it was paper i don't remember or
was it rock i think it was rock it was rock or paper oh see
you're a liar i'm gonna tell my group about you what i'm
gonna tell my group about you that you're a liar i'm packing
you up right now i'm packing you up right now
Squid, don't check Squid, he's a liar.
Squid's a liar, don't trust him.
Squid's a liar?
Squid.
Yeah, don't trust Squid.
Cool with you.
Ducky.
It's what we talked about.
Zerum, Zerum, Zerum.
I know.
Oh, okay.
I'm not lying.
What did you say?
No!
I'm sorry!
I appreciate you.
I will admit myself.
You tried lying to me!
I need to be back in the room.
This is too loud.
It's too loud.
You said skull and it was scroll.
Are you okay?
That was way too loud.
Yeah, that was a lot of people.
Why is the intro?
Did you win yours?
a liar don't trust me okay um pizza heads a truth there we
went for four we went okay okay i got two points i got i got
i got lied to yeah i got lied to i got four points i got two
points though hey i bet you're up guys yeah how much did
you're up guys EROB!
EROB, wake up!
He's immune!
Wake up!
Did you win or lose?
Bye!
Who was it?
I got light, so I got through.
Are you a liar?
You got me though, right?
I can't lie.
I have a problem.
I don't have any... I can't I can't do it.
well well well hey so i'm gonna just keep it a buck 50 with
you i'm two wins two losses we traded wins and losses with
my last person oh sweet god okay anyway don't trust squid
because he's a okay i'm thinking about you i don't know who
squid is but i'm thinking about you the person right in
front of me here yeah what item did you just get i got i got
a blade i want to trust you
This first round is going to decide how we're going to do
the rest of this game.
I'm willing to be trustworthy with you.
Okay, cool.
All right.
So I'm going to lock it in with 10 seconds left.
You got to blink.
Doki, don't do it.
Don't do it.
I know you lost round one.
Yeah.
I didn't lie about it.
Oh, wow.
You're actually being honest.
Yeah.
Now.
Okay.
I need to be smart about this.
Yeah.
Are you going to keep lying?
No.
No, no.
How about this?
You know you're not going to win the $70,000.
Who says, whoa, whoa, you said something I don't like you.
Wow.
That's a loser's mentality right there.
And I'm a winner.
I'm going to win it.
Wait, what item did I just get?
I think I missed it.
I don't know.
You have been assigned an item.
I can't see it.
Oh, there it is.
How did you see it?
You press F.
All right.
So I got a knife.
Okay.
so does that mean i get that round if you skull you will win
all right i'm putting that skull in you wouldn't lie to me
right nope i just met you but we just met but you wouldn't
lie to me right i'm literally a bear oh wait you're a
truther i'm a truther you're a truther i told you i went
back and forth exactly like this with my last person okay
because all you gotta do is not lose everything you just win
two and lose two you'll be in the middle you'll be fine you
get through okay all right i have a skull that ass you have
a skull yeah what's something you really care about in life
i care about you have animals like a pet whoa where you do
to my animal no what i'm saying is i want you to put that
promise if you're gonna promise all right if it's not a
skull i'll let you
Okay.
In Minecraft.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna trust you.
It's a scar!
We can get out of here alive.
Yeah.
Both of us.
See?
We can finish in the middle.
Oh, wait.
The timer's not up.
You're gonna win.
Wait, what?
Oh, sorry.
I thought the timer.
You have to wait until it's zero.
Mm-mm.
I would never lie to you.
I'm trusting you.
Nice.
Wow.
Yeah.
And now my turn.
Wait, whose turn is it?
It's my turn.
What do you have?
Dude, this is crazy.
Because I've been getting knife every single round.
I got a knife again.
Okay.
So I can put this then.
How much?
All right.
What do you love in life?
I love my mother.
Okay, well, I'm going to build a statue of your mom in
Minecraft.
If you lie to me.
And I'll blow it up.
Jokey.
I love my mom.
So I'm going to.
change my mind i said if you lied me oh all right i love my
mom too much is wrong bro yeah i would do i would post that
video up too on youtube and you should check my channel
subscriber and see how many people are gonna watch it it's a
draw okay so you did lie i lied you did lie Yay!
Charlie, who points are you right?
I'm at 11.
Are you like, are you like, I got five points.
Nice, and Eero, did you vote?
Every day all day.
I have five points.
How many ones do you have?
Who are you playing against?
I have, no, how do you see how many points you have?
Let's go Eero!
Oh, this is scary.
It's on the top left.
Tiny Mac that is cool, okay?
I got six.
Tiny Mac that is cool.
Okay, good.
BTMC is cool.
I went two wins one draw.
Okay, okay.
BTMC is not cool.
It's on top.
It's not cool.
He's not cool with you, Abe.
You're not cool with anyone, man.
Toki is not cool.
Wait, what do you mean?
What?
I've been a true three this entire time.
I'm nervous.
Toki, more like Duki.
Whoa!
Personally Nah, damn, I knew I should punch you out.
I knew I should punch you out I got six I got six I got
nine.
I got five.
Let's go.
I got 24 points Yeah, five points.
Oh How many points do you have?
I have ten points.
What the fuck?
What you've been lying to people?
You've been you're a liar This is a liar I haven't lied to
us.
You should be proud of that.
Yeah, you should not be proud of having 10 points because
you're a liar.
I literally have not lied once.
It's not my fault.
He's lying to us right now.
Yeah, yeah, he's lying to us.
He's not a good person because he's a liar.
Wait, is that actually?
Is that true, Abe?
Like people who just don't trust you so you get a few
points?
Yeah, I have 10 points.
I haven't lied once.
Everyone just trusts me.
Yeah, see you.
Dude, no, I have the inverse effect.
No one fucking trusts me.
Well, that's for good reason, man.
I wouldn't trust you either.
Oh shit.
Hello there.
Hey.
Are you a truther?
I am a truther actually.
I'm a firm believer that what we should do is, you know,
round one, I'll tell you what I have genuinely.
Yeah.
And you can win one and then you do the same and I get to
win one.
That's nice of you.
So first two rounds we don't play for real and then the
second two rounds we'll play for real.
Sure.
That'll be fun.
Okay, yeah.
So I have skull this time.
So you should do the scroll to win.
Yeah.
Like this?
Yeah, perfect.
Yeah.
And you wouldn't lie to me too, right?
No, I'm not lying.
No, you can, see, you'll be willing to do it because you're
going to know that I was truthing this whole time about it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I do have skull.
A hundred percent.
Wait, you, oh yeah, skull.
Okay.
Yeah.
Right.
I trust you.
Yeah.
You seem like you're a Minecraft player.
I'm doing a lot of faith here.
I'm trusting you preemptively.
Yeah.
Oh, hey, you're right.
All right.
What did I say?
I told you I was a truther.
Yeah, you're such a truther.
Okay.
I'll tell you what I have too.
Yeah.
I knew trusting Minecraft players was right.
idea that's what i'm saying all right i have a scroll okay
the scroll okay so i should go knife yeah yeah yeah i would
never lie to you after we established our bonds that's yeah
i mean after i gave you that first one sure yeah truly we're
like we just met you don't know my character yeah yeah but i
would never lie i mean you gave me two points so why would i
want another two points yeah why would you not want to also
give me two points yeah exactly kind of good that's kind of
That'd be so fucked up.
Then we can play for real, right?
Yeah, and then we play for real.
I mean, like, it'd be so fucked up if I just, like, yoying
two points off of you like that.
After you gave me...
After I gave you that free two points, like, what kind of
person am I to do that to you?
I would be heartbroken if that happened.
Okay, see?
Look, see?
I told you.
I told you I was truthing.
I would never fuck with you like that.
That's what I like to hear.
Okay, we're playing for real now?
Yeah, sure.
okay I I do you want me to tell you what I got still sure
okay I did in fact get the paper oh you got paper again I
did yeah the odds of that I've actually had paper the last
three times now that paper the last three times wait how
many points do you have around one with you right yeah yeah
yeah I had paper my last round and against the other person
as well yeah wait how many rounds how many points do you
have I'm at nine right now you have nine points damn wait
That means people have been lying to you Yeah, people have
been lying to me a bit That's so fucked up Why would they
lie to you like that?
Well, you know People be lying Yeah, you should get them
banned For lying Get them banned They're banned from the
Minecraft event They're liars Yeah, they're liars Oh, hey
Wait, you lied I was close I was close I wasn't even ready I
was close Okay, so how many points do you have?
Oh, you have seven.
Okay, see, I'm at a comfortable 10 right now.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, well, what did you get so I can give you these two
points?
I have a knife.
You have a knife?
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait, I thought you were going to give me those two points.
What happened?
I mean, I thought we were playing for real the last two
rounds.
Yeah, but then you're more alive than me?
Oh.
What's the thing that you love the most in life?
Um...
I don't know.
What's the thing?
Living, I guess.
Life is funny, you know.
Life is funny?
Yeah, it's a funny thing, you know.
Well, I hope you're happy living in hell.
Oh!
Oh, I'm a dream!
Oh, no!
I hope you live with that guilt for the rest of your life.
I thought you were lying, so then I...
I...
I have 10 points I need to start lying I got lied to again I
got lied to I got 7 I need to start Lying.
No, I need to start lying.
Kumi, you've been telling the truth.
Why the fuck have you been telling the truth?
You're losing.
Because I've always been telling the, because I don't tell
lies.
That's not true.
I don't tell lies.
You literally lied to me 24 seven.
Look at your fucking daytime job.
You eat, sleep, and shit lies.
I'm always a true thing.
Yeah, me neither, man.
Wait, how many more games do we have left?
Two more I think.
Two?
Okay.
Wait, how many do you have though?
Six, I think.
Don't, don't, don't trust.
I got eight.
But listen, I got lied to.
I got lied to by Iskell.
And he's Swedish.
Wait, maybe he's a fake Swede.
Yeah.
It was going well and then he lied to me.
That's fucked up.
Why don't you lie to?
True, true, true.
I might have to head to my lying or I'm gonna start.
You gotta start lying.
I gotta start lying too.
Wait, Kumi, we getting matched up.
Like we have known each other for so long, like you wouldn't
lie to me, right?
Yeah, I would never lie to you.
Of course.
What if you're lying right now?
I got, I've been tricked because I've been telling the
truth.
That's why seven points.
You wouldn't lie to me, right?
Of course, I would never lie to you.
No, it's bad because we were trading and he told me he had
Skull and I said, okay, I like you, I'm gonna give you the
win.
And I picked Blade and then he goes, no, it'll be a tie.
hey hey i've been having no i've been having a rough time
because everybody's lying to me i'm not a liar are you sure
promise are you sure i gotta i i'm gonna tell you now that i
got a knife okay i put a skull up i'm not lying are you sure
i'll be upset wait how many points do you have i got eight
you got eight i have i haven't been lying but i had two
people lying then i got a draw yeah i haven't been lying i
have three points because they all took advantage of my
truth yeah everybody's been taking advantage of me don't
worry because i haven't been lying at all i don't lie at all
either but i think that's kind of oh my god thank you now i
have five points Thank you.
That's so sweet of you.
I got you.
Don't worry.
I won't lie to you.
Okay.
Can I have another point so I can stay in the game?
And then I'll give you the next two points.
Okay.
Yay!
Um, paper.
Oh, then I need to do school.
Yeah.
Thank you!
I almost did paper again and gave it a draw, but...
That's so sweet.
I'll give you the for the next one and then we should I
would never no I didn't I'm just saying if you do I think I
have paper wait let me double check again yeah I have paper
I'm very forgetful too after this round no no I would never
I would never lie to you I'm scared no that's why I have
three points because people took advantage of my kindness I
thought I had an alliance and then they abused it see I okay
i mean like this round oh yeah yeah this round this round uh
what do you have i got a skull look see i never lied to you
gave me four points oh it did nice yeah i was trying to tell
people earlier i was like you get more points if we just
work together i know like i don't understand why people
don't work together like it's so messed up it's minecraft i
thought minecraft's all to swear in minecraft and people are
lying yeah what do they think this is among us yeah this is
a christian sir god will not like this the next one do you
want to would you rather just do like like a wrong one
rather than a plus four yeah we could just do like wait what
do you mean by that you said oh no no no this is plus two
Okay, never mind.
I think I misunderstood the point system.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shut up.
Wait, is that the last round, right?
Yes.
Oh, can I have two more points so I can not get eliminated?
Yeah.
Yay!
Um, I am Blade.
You're so nice.
Oh my god, you have been the nicest person I've like bumped
into.
That's so sweet.
I can't believe other people were taking advantage of your
kindness.
I know, right?
That's so messed up.
I bet those people...
They're going to go to hell.
Especially on Minecraft.
I know, especially in this Christian Minecraft survey.
You know they're never going to win that $70,000.
You know?
You're taking it so seriously.
I need that.
Oh my God, thank you.
Is that the last one or do we have another one?
No, that was definitely the last one.
Yay.
That's so easy.
Guys, I got 13 points.
Whoa!
I got 12.
I got 13.
What you got, bro?
Mendo, how many you got?
12, 12.
I'm chilling, bro.
I'm 13.
What's good, brother?
Mendo, Mendo, bro, you gotta step it up.
12 is bad.
Dude, I can't lie.
They'll feel bad if I lie.
You gotta step it up.
You have to, like, take it.
I can't, dude!
What a big issue!
Oh my god, this isn't my new track, Guilt Tripping.
Who said that?
My new trick.
I don't know, I can't either, bro.
I can't do it.
What's your points, Abe?
They're all too nice.
What do you want to do, Abe?
What points do you have?
I can't take that away from you, man.
Did she have...
You have 19?
I don't even know how to put your foot down.
my god i can't even hear you it's so loud i just missed
myself man no no like i can't lie like my heart guys i can't
believe it i've got 13 points guys i might be safe maybe
wait is this the last game one round yeah i think it's one
one round left i think you're gonna be on site for day three
Yeah, yeah.
What if it's us too?
Oh, no.
But how many points do you have?
That guy has 20.
14.
I'm 13.
I think we could be eliminated.
I think we might be...
I think we're...
I felt so bad.
I think we're fucked.
No, I'm sorry.
No, no, surely not.
I think we're fucked.
That's not a lot of points.
13's not a lot.
I'm sorry for lying.
14.
Oh, no.
Guys, I'm scared.
got taken advantage in the beginning so then I took
advantage of somebody else.
But now, like, I feel like we're not going to be able to
make it, guys.
Alright, Doki, good luck.
Good luck, good luck, guys.
Good luck.
Hi,
Doki.
Hey, are you a truther?
I have been truthful with everyone I've played against.
Really?
How many points do you have?
I have 15.
15?
I have 6.
So people...
No, I've been...
People have been taking advantage of me.
Because I've been telling the truth.
I got, like, squid in the first game.
And then he, like, took advantage of me.
And then I got some other guy with, like, a creeper thing.
A creeper skin.
And then he also, like, made me lose almost everybody.
So, like...
What do you have?
I have...
I have a skull.
You have a skull?
Yeah.
Oh my god, thank you!
This is the way I've been doing it with everyone.
I give them the first one and then we go back and forth.
You don't have to, but that's the way I've been doing it.
Wait, can I have another point though?
Because I might get eliminated?
Sure.
Yay!
Thank you.
I have a knife.
Knife?
Okay.
Ah, you put the skull.
You wouldn't lie, right?
have you been telling the truth you haven't lied a single
time okay you you said you went against the creeper skin no
no they lied to me they kept lying because they were like
they gave me uh they told the truth for the first two rounds
and then they told lies in the last the last two rounds to
me so then they like won yeah so they took advantage because
they were like because they were like oh i'm gonna tell the
truth the entire time he's like really so then i just
trusted him thank you all right all right i'll let you win
the next one all right see i thought in the last game this
is where like we were gonna start seeing you know the real
sides of people the real sides but you wouldn't lie though i
wouldn't i yeah so can the last round can i have the two
points then Yeah.
Because you're in the comfortable place, aren't you?
I don't know.
Wait, what's your point?
Uh, well, I had, I've got 15.
Oh.
Yeah, no, you're comfortable.
I don't know how...
I saw her, like, some people, I heard it was, like, 12 and,
like, seven.
So I think you're in a comfortable place.
I have a knife.
You have a knife?
Okay.
Yeah, and I'm telling the truth.
I believe you.
Yeah, because you've been telling the truth this entire
time.
I wonder, though, how many people are going to do kind of
what we're doing right now?
What, like, exchanging stuff?
Yeah.
So it all kind of levels out at the end.
Oh, I know, like, there's some people with, like, seven
points.
So I think you should be fine.
That means there's got to be people with, like, 25, right?
I think the highest I heard was 20.
All right, what do you have?
Even that's still insane.
So are you okay if I take the last two?
two points.
I'm fine with that.
Oh, okay, thank you.
What do you have?
Paper.
Paper?
Hi.
Did you ever watch Splitter Steel?
Splitter Steel?
Wait, what's that?
Like, any game shows where two people have to decide whether
they like, if they're given like money, they have to choose
their Oh, and then like you're like, oh, if you pick the
money up, then you'll lose it for everybody like type deal
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i never thought i'd be doing that
in real life i know it's actually crazy i can't believe
people are liars still thank you so much for the points i
really appreciate it how many do you have i have i think i
have you lost 15 minutes guilt-tripping i got eliminated you
got eliminated how many points you have i'm surprised No
way, no way!
Wait, sleepy, you got eliminated!
No, we got eliminated!
Yeah, Mendo, I told you, bro.
Oh my god!
Mendo.
I can't lie to them, man, I can!
Who beat us all thanks to you?
What?
I didn't do nothing.
How important did you get?
Oh, that is actually...
That is evil!
You're actually a villain, though.
I appreciate you
Oh, yeah, no, I like That's not only 30 people I trust you
I'm just gone now My god I can't believe it Are you okay?
Are you okay, man?
Okay down together i trusted you and we did it we did it but
it wasn't enough man i can't believe it i can't believe it i
made it to the next day guys all right turn off emo mode
only turn off emo mode like easily too we were six points
away from right
Oh my god.
Guys, if all else fails, it's guilt tripping time.
I got it.
That was evil.
How is that evil?
I made it through.
No.
Going to hell Guys, I made it!
Let's go!
I'm game I made it to the next next round People gave me
free points And I survived
Kevin Oh my god Let's do it Why would they scare me like
that?
No, I'm just getting to win.
I'm just getting to win.
I won, bro.
Look, I just lied.
It was just a little white lie, guys.
Everyone's got 20 points.
I've only got 16, chat.
Just a little white lie.
Oh, my God.
Is it safe you are?
Yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How many points did you get again?
18.
I got 19.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, you know how I did it?
I guilt shifted.
I was like, I only have three points.
Can I please have some points?
I can stay in the round a little longer.
Oh my god, so you did that.
And then they gave me three rounds.
Both players gave me three rounds.
Did they die?
Did those players die?
No, no, they didn't die.
Because they were already comfortable.
As they were already comfortable.
So I was like, hey, you guys are going to make it anyway.
So like, can I have the three rounds?
I only have three points.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
A lot of my friends live.
Oh, nice.
I guess we're living to the next day.
Oh, my God, Batoki.
I feel so bad.
I lied to one person.
Who did you lie to?
There was a person who lied to me first, and I was like, oh.
I want to go see who lost the last room.
And then I just lied to them at the last room.
Oh, they deserve it.
They deserve it.
We made it.
I thought it was funny that Mendo and Sleepy got kicked.
No, that's crazy.
I really wouldn't want Sleeping.
Sleeping was so cocky, too, earlier.
He was like, I got the point.
Yeah.
I mean, I thought Sleeping was in for sure.
Yeah, me too.
I was not expecting his elimination.
Oh my wait, what's the now?
It's time to decide your future.
What the fuck is that?
Dave, Dave, Dave got eliminated.
I don't know.
I wonder what that is.
Hi, Dave.
How many points did you end up with yeah well how many
points did you have you didn't save mendo oh okay whatever
all right whatever you didn't even save mendo oh we woke up
we woke up and did you make it i didn't make it use this to
talk to you i talked to other contestants let's go we have
the last easter egg
We did it.
You see, people lie about rock what they had.
Skull, blade, or paper, or scroll.
I am at another level of lying.
I was at a different level.
Very evil yet very cool.
Nobody thought about it.
a line to pull up the points.
I'm not going out day one.
How many did you have?
No, I traded a bunch of them.
I had one round where I had destroyed them.
Big brain.
It's just twisted truth.
You traded all the way until the last one.
The last one was the person who lied to me.
Yeah, with everyone, I was doing the first two we trade to
each get two points and then this guy lied to me if you want
or we can keep trading that's what i did yeah he lied to me
you lied to her i did not yeah i did one though we traded
are you in a time room and then the last two we played for
real yeah but then you lied Yeah,
and the way I played the game was I was a truthful person
Yeah,
he caused my Joker arc I was a truthful person He corrupted
me I was a truther until he corrupted me So I had to start
lying I had to start guilt tripping people You had to do it,
you had to do it Yeah, yeah, there was no other choice My
Joker art started it Oh, do not leave the server Wait, what
we're supposed to do Yeah, I used to be a very trustworthy
person And now people Now I have to lie Alright No Yeah What
do we even get for the Easter eggs I don't know, what if you
get a total drama islanding Where you don't get kicked out
oh like if you get out yeah but then everybody's gonna try
and get 10 then and then they can't kick out anyone after
yeah but not everyone like you didn't try and get 10.
yeah but like now i'm going to try we have six days of this
and the server and the server is like up like an hour like
more than an hour before the event starts too because i
logged into the server at like, uh, 11.
Yeah.
Wait, where are you?
I lost you.
I'm right behind you, man.
Oh, what the heck?
You're camouflage!
I don't think there's any eggs here.
There's one over here.
Follow me, though.
Oh, okay.
I only have one.
I haven't been paying attention.
Well, I could get eliminated tomorrow, chat.
Like, the thing is, you can get eliminated at any day.
Yeah, right.
Is there an egg here, guys?
Yeah, there should be, right?
Oh, there it is.
Got it.
Wait, where is it?
It's so happy.
Does anybody know where the, like, the 10th egg is?
What?
Yeah.
Stand where I am.
Stand where.
Come here.
Oh, come here.
I'm here.
Oh, snap.
What?
Selecting people for tiebreakers.
Jump.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Wait, there's tiebreakers.
Oh, it's right here.
Yeah, because apparently people tied with points and then
they're gonna duke it out.
Wait, is it like a...
Wait, how do we...
How do we like find it?
Oh, yeah, I hit that one.
Oh, I had 19 points, so like...
No, no, no, tiebreakers are for the people who weren't in
our room.
Oh!
Our room was the only one with no tiebreaker.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
There's two in this room, Doki.
where um there is a tv over there yeah yeah yeah yeah i see
it wait have you found all 10 already no no i only found
eight oh my and then there's another one over here okay i
have three i wonder if we can watch the tiebreaker i'm gonna
be real i know dr gluon yeah i mean we're not allowed to
leave yet we should be allowed to watch the tiebreaker i
don't think i Well, that was...
Well, you're loud, you could say.
If you watch the stream.
Wait, we can't watch it.
Let's get this way.
Oh, I'm over there.
What did you have?
I had 18.
I had 16.
I almost got somebody eliminated, though.
Because they were, like, what, 17 or something?
They literally just...
Pat lived.
Oh, my God.
I'm nervous, Miri.
How do we do this?
I could.
Could have let them die.
And then one right here.
Oh, okay.
Oh, now I have seven.
Wait, how did you have eight then?
Where's the eighth one?
There should be another one right here.
Wait, where?
What tree?
Contestants will compete in our battle.
Where was the last one you got?
Oh, over here.
Oh, okay.
People said there's some outside.
Yeah, we got the tree outside already.
Oh, wait, is this the same outside?
side oh yeah yeah there should be more around here oh are we
gonna watch them i don't know yeah i got it all right let's
see we watch them oh my gosh i guess we watch oh my god
that's so cool guys write this down guys we're gonna steal i
mean borrow this for our own stuff for our own Gumi, where
are you?
Goki, where are you going?
Oh, I am here.
Guys, write this down.
Oh, we're at me.
That's from VTuber.
It's T-T-T.
Look, look, look.
You see, people are, like, running with particles.
If they have a particle, you don't want to be near them.
You just need to, like, run away, you know?
Oh, my God.
Oh, okay.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I'm actually going to pee my pants.
I don't know.
I'm waiting to watch this game right now.
Oh, wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
The sound effects are so scary.
It's like crab game.
It's just like crab game.
You know with the stick?
Yeah, the hot potato.
That is not enough tile.
That is absolutely not enough tile.
Oh, there's no way.
that is not enough time yeah it's like 20 seconds you got
through um with 16 points and ice top um open water lost and
i think he had 17 because green was so competitive you just
shifted over there oh no there's no way silver man i just
thought i'm dead for him yeah so do you have to try even see
they just have like oh I guess like one elimination criteria
met wait who lived who lived I feel like anyone that got
like the curse lost automatically because that was so brutal
yeah I feel like I feel like if you have the curse you just
automatically you automatically lose there's no way Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Yeah, map's too big and the time's too short there.
I hope they adjust that.
It seems pretty unfair.
Guys, I did not expect to make it to day two.
I thought I was gonna have like a one-week vacation.
Well, I mean, like...
Most likely I'll be eliminated on day two.
I don't think I'm gonna...
No, you're fine.
You're fine.
You got 30 seconds.
You need to track them the fuck down.
maybe maybe i feel like i feel like i'm gonna eliminate that
there's no way i'll live past the second day these guys are
minecraft players find the 10th egg oh you're right wait
another one there's another tiebreaker i don't know if you
guys knew but i could hear you and i heard oh my god there's
another okay guys do you guys know where the uh easter eggs
are We're gonna try.
Oh my god, so many tiebreakers.
I already discovered this.
Multiple teams needed.
Multiple teams needed to...
Oh, oh, I thought that was like everybody.
Oh, I guess because like each color had tiebreakers.
Guys, stream swipe time.
Where's the last...
Where's the last TV?
Yeah, for each color.
Oh, because ours was the one that...
didn't have the thing bottom guys bottom right is not an
answer
bottom right is not an answer guys bottom left toky shit
you're right let me go check bottom left it's over there
it's there here up there that i understand why we had to
have emote only if we If you didn't have emote only, you
guys would have fucking broke my, uh...
You guys would have fucking snitched me out.
On the guilt trip.
You guys would have 100% snitched me out.
No, we already got that TV.
We already got that.
He's right here.
You've got the silver!
I'm no idea who these people are.
I guess I'll cheer for it.
I'll cheer for the first person I see.
That's what I'm saying.
Like, bro, there's no way he's going to get... He has 20
seconds to get to him.
There's no way.
Oh my god, he's so far away, my render is gone.
He's so far away, my render distance.
He doesn't make it.
Oh my head.
Chosen that.
Yes.
Yeah.
Look at everybody knows.
Where is Silva?
Oh!
Wait, he actually caught somebody.
She did it!
Oh my god, the first person to catch somebody.
Oh my god, the very first one.
There they are.
Silver have it?
I don't think there's enough time for someone to get
somebody on.
I don't think Silver has it.
Yeah, everybody.
It's to be.
This game mode is...
Wait, they didn't test this, surely.
The streamer's not testing stuff?
No way.
Wait, what?
That's it?
That's so fast.
That was so fast.
Real.
The streamer is actually testing video games?
No fucking way.
Kratos.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, there's no way.
Maybe there should be...
Maybe there's a TV in the bedroom.
Do you think there's TVs in the bedroom?
We literally are missing, like, one TV.
We got all the other TVs.
We're just missing one TV left.
Check the graveyard.
There's a graveyard?
Wait, there's a fucking graveyard?
Yeah, I wish we had, like, the invisible flying.
I think the invisible flying.
Oh, the purple portal.
You can go through that?
Okay, let's check it out.
Let's check it out.
Oh.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's head to the portal.
We have two more.
Wait, I might be like the last V-tuber.
What's this?
These are everybody that died.
Right?
No, who the fuck are these people?
There's no way.
Wait, that's me!
I'm dead!
Oh my god.
I'm secretly a ghost.
Alright guys, I don't think they're in the graveyard.
I don't think a TV is in the graveyard, guys.
Yeah, this is everybody's.
Oh, the ones that didn't make it are like...
A tombstone.
Oh, I see.
The ones that didn't make it are too... Wait, they didn't
teleport us.
Is it because, like, we're in the graveyard?
Wait, I didn't get teleported!
No!
Oh, wait, no, they didn't start yet.
No.
They didn't start yet.
Yeah, and Esther.
I'll never find the last... What the fuck?
Oh, it was so fast.
Maybe not.
Who are the two people that are live?
They told us not to disconnect, so...
So I'm, like...
I'm, like, being a good person.
Actually, hacks!
They said don't leave, so I'm actually listening!
There's no way.
He's not gonna find him.
Bro, he's not gonna fucking find him.
I have no idea.
Bro, he can't even find it.
That's so fucked.
It's so fucked.
He doesn't even know where he is.
Oh, another VTuber gone.
Oh, wait, unless...
Oh, unless...
Oh, no, no, that's the...
Oh, here we go.
This is so rare.
I wish we could, like, fly.
Good job, good job, good job.
I can't believe you survived.
Good job.
i think i'm like intruding i'm definitely intruding on
something oh nice he lived i'll never find the last easter
egg i'll never find it
where the heck is the last tv how was i supposed to know i
think this last day guys actually scrambled it and it
doesn't exist in the end straight up aided it i hope
everybody that lied to me and started my joker arc does not
win do you not let's not win top 20 yeah i'm just waiting so
fast i hope they don't win I hope they wasted their time and
then get eliminated on day four.
That's so...
I hope they get eliminated day four because that's a cutoff
when the money stops.
When the money just starts going in.
That's all I care about.
That's so evil.
All of those people that started my Joker.
Like...
There's like two outside here.
So there should be two outside the other area.
It's not a waste.
It's both exposure.
Yeah, but it's not $70,000.
You know what?
No, I hope one of them was just barely set.
Like, they get second place.
So they feel like shit.
that they didn't win first.
Harry discovered that.
God, that sucks when he barely missed out on the 70k.
So that's what they get for lying to me.
No, it's like top 20, so I think like first is 70,000.
Second is...
What is second again, guys?
Do you guys know what second is?
Because I don't remember.
I just know first is...
first is 70k because it's fucking 70 grand um and then 12k
okay second is i'm second is like 12 grand and then third to
20th is um third to 20th is 1k wait gumi found the last
easter egg
wait where's gumi where's gumi where is she are you sure
you're in yes i'm 100 sure he's the person Tripped it was
lower points than me, but they made it.
That's why I know.
Top bright guys.
Which outside?
This outside?
The other outside?
It has to be this other.
Oh my god, I love this guy's skin.
No!
I was so close outside!
I was so close!
Oh, that's not the outside.
No!
Yeah.
Oh, I just saw Gumi too.
Oh, it's not outside.
Okay.
Now we know where the TV is.
I'm glad we got through this day.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm gonna take the high ground.
What Twitch says, no outside.
Ask for coordinates.
Show your coordinates, Doki!
Find the coordinates!
Yeah, yeah.
Hey.
They're like near the edge.
Silver, if you have like, if you have a potato, do you have
it at all?
No, I didn't.
Can you, can you say something?
just got lucky i don't even think you i don't know shout out
to who it's so uh fuzzy snugs can you say that fussy snugs
oh my gosh oh yeah yeah yeah okay what's in it for me you
probably have that big below it's so what's in it for me you
get to make somebody happy i guess i'll tell you what this
is a cameo yes yes i'm asking for a cameo all right okay
follow me on twitter and i'll
Man, I can say, no, what's for me for one?
You know, like, yeah.
Wait, I'm doing a favor for you!
I'm doing a favor for you!
Listen, there is no incentive for me.
I just said that it was so very simply.
Somebody in my stream chat is a big fan.
Yeah, and I'm doing you a favor.
Not me a favor.
I don't care what happens, okay?
I just...
Yeah, but like...
So you hate your chat.
You're not only the 40 on Twitter.
It's one click.
I definitely do hate my chat, but you can't say you can't
say two words.
You can't say ah, shout out Swazzy Snuggs Shout out Jesse.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you see, but who's the big person now?
That's in your chat.
That's not my chat.
Listen, I don't know who you want, but apparently they do,
okay?
So, you know, what it's gonna be for me?
It's one click.
Oh, you're not willing to do one click just to
Damn, that's fucked up.
He's not really the...
But he's just showed us that I got a turkey.
He showed up to snow.
This is snunky for us.
It's so rude.
Why am I the rude one?
They asked me for us.
shout out i was like all right one click follow me on
twitter just funny just one click two words it's a good
exchange i give you a two words one click clicking is free
yeah clicking is free
yeah go and follow me on twitter yeah equivalent exchange
it's just business Yeah, you didn't even have to stay for
all of them.
Hey, guys.
If you're from Sonic Fox's chat, I would never do that to
you.
I love my chat.
Red dragons.
I will never do that to you guys.
Is that TV?
Is there a TV here?
Right here.
Me?
Is there a TV here?
Yeah.
Where is it?
I can't see.
Where is the TV?
Under?
Guys, I need...
Guys, I need you guys to translate!
And the whole gang's over here!
I'm gonna see you.
Finally, that's crazy.
Wait, I see it!
Oh my god!
I followed the Minecrafters!
Translated.
We did it.
We got everything.
We got everything, guys.
got everything perfect game we did
oh my god that one was hard okay oh it's across the that one
was working all right let me see i'm gonna check that one
i'm gonna check if he followed what how do you know this is
important guys we gotta know
say dinner, follow, no no shout, I no shout out no shout out
that was broadcast on the main Rylos channel all the, us all
fucking bunching up the, that entire conversation wait,
really?
Wait, that entire conversation I had no fucking Wait...
Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
There's no way!
Come on!
Oh no!
I got exposed!
I want the hair.
Damn.
I got exposed.
Exposed showing the world!
What do you mean?
They...
Sci-Fox literally said, they literally said, I hate my chat!
It caught them in 4k It caught They got caught on 4k And I
was like Whoa I would never
Oh hey Hey you ready to play Valorant Oh Oh yeah I almost
forgot about that Yeah you can never forget about it Wait
wait wait Right now I need to get lunch first And then I can
play But I'll be playing I won't be streaming it though Okay
Okay, you got lunch, Kristen, and we can play.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it over yet?
Like, where are we waiting for it?
Yeah, it's over.
Oh, okay, because, like, they never said you're allowed to
leave now.
Yeah?
I got all 10 eggs.
Oh, me too!
I found it, yeah!
What the heck?
I found all 10.
You found it in the dark?
Yeah, the last one's at the dark.
Wait, how many do you have, Ant?
I have eight right now.
What the fuck?
You just started laughing at that?
That was a crazy laugh, by the way.
I have 10 what happens now I don't think it's just nothing
you just it's just like bragging power by having 10 you get
to laugh at people who don't have 10 like that there's one
that I didn't get yet I need to get that one there's one
outside that's really fucked up yeah is it like a tree
because I didn't get that one no it's really it's really
fucked up I'm gonna go grab lunch I'll see you later with me
dm me dm me all right all right guys we made it guys we made
it today too i can't believe my my whole conversation was
put up on stream we made cheese i had a great time um good
time interacting with people i've interacted with before
yeah and um how dare and like i had a good time Like, okay,
the first...
The first one, the first one was, like, really fucked up,
though.
I think the first game was super fucked up.
That one was messed up for me.
Like, I literally could not actually play the game.
And it took so long.
It took so long.
I could barely, like, take in anything that was going on in
the first one.
And I felt like that should have been much shorter 100% But
the second one was fun The second game was really fun I
think the best part was just interacting Nobody expected me
to make it to the second game But we did it Yeah I was
running a goddamn marathon I was running a goddamn marathon
In the first game I was like please let this be over And I
was doing it wrong I was doing the marathon wrong too
because i wasn't holding space because i didn't i don't know
the minecraft tech uh the second game was fun i had a great
time in the second game um i still can't believe mendo and
sleepy didn't make it through like what the fuck they were
so confident earlier like jokie bird was born today um but
yeah i'll see you guys tomorrow i think it's the same time
um it's the same time and uh and there's also two games so
we'll see if we get eliminated but anyway guys I'm gonna
call here already to Agumi since like I'll be showing up
after lunch after I get food but anyway guys as always
everybody stay hydrated pause your check get up and move
around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me
head to bed or I don't know stay up for Valorant because you
deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody oh shit
never mind let's take a group picture JK i want to be part
of the group picture exposure wait main stairs okay guys we
gotta get the exposure we made it to day one they're gonna
post your picture screenshot bro the minecraft streamers are
gonna post the screenshot guys pre-exposure yeah i'll be the
one that like awkwardly crouches i'm in a sorority i'm in a
sorority crouch yes sorority crouch
actually don't have a custom skin wait what's up what's the
hey to show you guys what i'm wearing in front of us wiki
what the fuck that's bad is that bad all right this is my
skin hey hey hey hey hey
check it out check it out Take a picture for me.
I'll make brown beer now.
Photo, photo, photo.
Photo, photo.
Say queso, say queso, queso.
Queso.
Oh my god.
Cheese.
Holy shit.
That was so loud.
Yeah, sorry guys.
Sorry, yes, I was really loud.
I was like, when am I supposed to look?
I don't understand.
I looked away.
No!
I didn't know!
Alright, but yeah, this is me.
Yo, yo, can we disconnect now already?
This is me.
This is my customs.
You can also get the skin just like this.
This is actually my OG skin.
I've had the skin for years.
I've had this skin Since I had a Minecraft account So it's
like actual Oh gee, it's not like I put it on It's not like
I put this on like Three, six months ago I actually had this
skin like for the last five to six years
I've always been a bear So I never changed it I've never
changed this skin Just another another skin suit all right
if anyone wants to make a custom skin for me it has to have
the qualities of the bear skin it has to have parts of the
bear skin guys that's all i ask for it
it has to have some qualities of this guys that's all i ask
it's like it's part of the it's part of my lore i've always
been a bear Before the skin suit, I had a bare skin suit.
But, like, not in, like, a furry type of way.
Just...
I'm just saying.
It was just in Minecraft.
Just in Minecraft.
Just in Minecraft, guys.
I just thought it was cute.
Just in Minecraft.
Alright, guys.
Now I'm actually at the go now, guys.
I'll see you guys later, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.